monsieur bonsoir la france en direct ce
soir édition spéciale pourquoi ça bloque
au septième jour au huitième jour de la
grève de la sncf
rejoint par les agents de la ratp
parfois de la poste est aussi d'edf gdf
il nous a semblé indispensable de
provoquer ce soir cette émission les
missions d'explication émission
également destinée à faire le point de
la situation
il nous a semblé qu'il était de notre
devoir de service public de présenter ce
soir
cette émission de bruit alors pour
comprendre les raisons de ces blocages
pour voir s'il s'agit d'un refus des
réformes ou d'une évolution plus
profonde de la société et bien nous
allons nous rendre d'abord sur les
endroits symboliques de ces lieux de
manifestations d'abord au moment où il y
à la barre des manifestants qui occupent
un dépôt de la sncf depuis déjà huit
jours maintenant à strasbourg nous irons
dans un centre postal à aubervilliers
nous nous rendrons sur un centre de
l'airé tp là aussi qui a rejoint le
mouvement il ya peu et puis à toulouse
nous irons voir les étudiants de la
faculté qui comme vous le savez sont
très en pointe dans le mouvement depuis
le début du conflit
nous serons en duplex bien sûr avec les
principales centrales syndicales à
commencer par monsieur blondel pour
force ouvrière
et puis ici sur le plateau et bien nous
réfléchirons sur les évolutions de cette
société avec des hommes politiques bien
sûr de droite et de gauche
dans la mesure où les représentants du
gouvernement n'ont pas souhaité
participer à cette émission alors qu'ils
sont en pleine négociation
et puis nous réfléchirons avec des
chercheurs des scientifiques qui et
analyse les évolutions de la société
française sur les raisons de ces
blocages leur première invitée premier
intervenant bien entendu monsieur marc
blondel monsieur blondel bonsoir bien
alors monsieur blondel
c'est vous finalement qui est le leader
de cette grève c'est vous qui depuis
huit jours maintenant avait décidé de
paralyser progressivement le pays alors
ce soir quelle est votre stratégie la
paralysie totale
écoutez je voudrais remettre les choses
au point ce n'est pas moi qui ai décidé
de paralyser le pays
celui qui a décidé de paralyser le pays
c'est le premier ministre à partir du
moment où il a fait une déclaration
devant le parlement qui modifiait de
fond en comble le principe de la
sécurité sociale qui était appliquée
depuis 50 ans
je crois qu'on n'a pas mesuré
l'importance de cette réforme qui est
une véritable destruction et n'ont pas
mis sous tutelle mais sous
administration judiciaire de la sécurité
sociale à partir de là il ya eu des
réactions différentes selon les secteurs
d'activité notamment les cheminots parce
que ça remettait en cause le régime
particulier mais aussi les
fonctionnaires parce que ça remet en
cause d'une certaine façon le statut de
la fonction publique
et puis aussi les gens qui maintenant
comprennent que la sécurité sociale va
être rationné en quelque sorte et qu'ils
ne seront plus sur deux mains d'avoir
les mêmes avances ya 16 ans sans vouloir
jouer les avocats d'il ya tout de même
on al'impression qu'avec vous bien il
faut toucher à rien c'est bien comme ça
a ajouté je vais essayer de préciser les
choses
c'est une fée de mètres de communication
on a essayé de me montrer comme étant
quelqu'un legrand immobiliste
l'immobilisme les journaux les médias
je ne parle pas de télévision d'ailleurs
merci fait remarquer que j'étais un
homme incapable d'accepter une évolution
et on après on a attaqué le dossier de
la sécurité sociale et lorsqu'on attaque
et le dossier de la sécurité sociale on
a refusé d'expliquer qu'on avait chargé
la bruine
je m'excuse de la liberté de langage
jouant mais je veux dire par là qu'on a
indiqué qu'elle était en déficit
parce que l'état ne tenez pas ses
engagements et il a persisté malgré nos
propositions il a perduré dans cette
situation ça veut donc dire qu'en fait
on a dit regardez vous est déficitaire
et nous nous disions nous regardons les
choses si on affecte les dépenses comme
il faut nous ne sommes pas déficitaire
monsieur blondel avant d'entrer dans le
vif du sujet sur les le fond de des
oppositions que que vous avez on va
faire un petit tour d'horizon déjà avec
monsieur de la rue jean claude delarue
qui
riche d'une association d'usagers pour
voir un petit peu les effets concrets
quotidien de ces manifestations sur les
usagers monsieur delarue bonsoir dans un
premier temps on a eu l'impression que
les usagers comprenait les
manifestations maintenant a la passion
puisque vous voulez sans doute ils
organisent une manifestation que eh bien
il y a un petit peu de de mécontentement
de votre côté choix que de choisir même
temps est à la fois effectivement
beaucoup d'usagers qui apparemment les
années sondages le montrent semblait
éprouver de la sympathie pour les
revendications de beaucoup de grévistes
est en même temps une très grande
majorité de français qui veulent quand
même pouvoir les travailler ce droit
aller au travail est essentiel lui
tranquille partagé par plus des deux
tiers des français à l'heure actuelle et
se traduit pas dans la réalité à l'heure
actuelle c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons absolument et ses sens
notamment la manifestation que nous
organisons demain à paris à 15 heures
place du châtelet c'est que précisément
on accepte de laisser comme c'est le cas
à cergy à creil et dans d'autres villes
d'être manipulés par la majorité pour
organiser cette manifestation vous savez
non je crois qu'il ya effectivement des
journaux qui ont dit que des partis
politiques voulaient utiliser le
mécontentement des 100 d'usagé pour
faire une opération politicienne
ça n'a strictement aucun rapport
d'opérations contre bat contre les
grèves alain non il y aura une
manifestation des gens qui sont contre
les grèves il y aura beaucoup de gens
qui sont favorables ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle en tout cas qu'ils
veulent soutenir les rêveries sur le
fond du problème
ils ont tous un point commun ils veulent
pouvoir les travailler alors maintenant
françois duteil cgt secrétaire de la cgt
bessieux détail bon soir soir bien alors
pas exactement la même question car
monsieur blondel mais ça y ressemble
fortement quel est votre détermination
jusqu'où voulez-vous aller ce soir est
ce que vous êtes prêts à la paralysie
progressive et complète du pays si vous
pouvez l'obtenir bien entendu la balle
dans le camp du gouvernement des
directions d'entreprise les salariés
sont déterminés
l'action n'arrive pas comme un coup
d'orage dans un ciel sans nuage
cela fait très longtemps que les
cheminots les écrits siens gazier les
postiers alerté le gouvernement leur
dirai son entreprise sur les dangers qui
menacent le service public et il est
vrai que les mesures annoncées par alain
juppé concernant la retraite a été la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
est aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
personnels en lutte demande le retrait
du plan juppé demande
une poursuit la discussion sur le
contrat de plan la sncf
le ministre de ne pas accepter cet après
midi ce sont les salariés
démocratiquement qui vont décider de la
poursuite de l'action il s'agit pas
d'exploiter un mécontentement plus
profonde de jouer le fameux troisième
tour social
non non écouter les élections c'est une
chose trop sérieuse pour qu'on parle de
troisième tour social les salariés se
détermine en toute conscience comme ils
l'ont fait quels que soient les
gouvernements et il est vrai que le
président de la république a changé de
ton il avait indiqué que la sécu tu es
malade du chômage
or aujourd'hui le chômage perdure elle
s'attaque à la sécu il a parlé de
service unique à la française qu'il
fallait de maintenir que ce soit france
télécom avec les déclarations du
ministre des états unis edf gdf ou à la
sncf c'est le service unique qui est
remis en cause ce sont les usagers qui
demain seront pénalisés et nous sommes
pour une vraie modernisation des
services uniques ce qui passe par
revenir à la notion d'usagé est pas en
termes de clients comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'on aurait accès aux
services uniques selon qu'on ait de
l'argent que l'on n'ait pas alors
messieurs duteil avant d'autres shows
pareil un heureux de revenir sur le fond
du débat les conséquences de cette grève
avec monsieur bébéar monsieur mebara
bonsoir vous êtes chef d'entreprise le
président du groupe axa qu'est ce que ça
représente pour vous cette seule grève
ce mouvement social mais pour moi ça
représente beaucoup d'employés qui se
lève à 4 heures du matin pour aller
travailler et qui n'ont vraiment
ras-le-bol
c'est à dire que je voudrais dire à aux
messieurs qui viennent me parler que
service public ça veut dire au service
du public et qu' il doit y avoir au
moins un service minimum alors quand
vous avez des gens comme ce que je vois
tous les jours d'autres pans tech de
salut leur conscience professionnelle
qui sont obligés de faire trois heures
quatre heures dans les transports
eh bien je dis qu'il n'ya plus de
service public alors qu'on ne me parle
pas de service public
le la notion de garantie de l'emploi
doit être lié à une obligation de
service public si vous n'avez plus si
vous ne rendait plus le service public
à ce moment là il ya aucune raison
d'avoir des certitudes quelque chose qui
m'a frappé depuis le début de cette
grève
je vous en rencontre c'est que
finalement les gens acceptent de faire
ce chemin tous les matins deux ou trois
heures mais d'une certaine façon pour un
certain nombre et c'est assez nouveau
ils disent finalement les fonctionnaires
et bien ils revendiquent pour nous parce
que nous dans le privé on peut pas le
faire est ce que vous avez vous avez
perçu sa beauté dans les discussions que
j'ai avec les gens chez moi c'est pas
cela qui disent non c'est à dire que
vous avez des implants ce plan qu'elle
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord mais
tout de suite
partir en grève car je ne crois pas que
ce que j'ai entendu tout à l'heure sur
tout à fait la vérité on part en grève
tout de suite
a priori avant même que discuter et ça
je vous assure que les employés chez
nous ne le comprenne bien alors nous
allons maintenant on non non c'est une
le ferroviaire très importants dont on
va là-bas des femmes et des hommes de la
sncf qui sont en compagnie de reporter
oui présentez vous avant de vous
exprimer oui bonjour je suis madame
olichon pascal oui au service voyageurs
de la gare du mans je suis marié et j'ai
trois enfants bien alors que voulez vous
nous dire ce soir mais je voulais vous
dire d'abord que les cheminots ne sont
pas vraiment pas content de cette
situation que ça ne fait pas plaisir de
laisser nos trains au garage qu'on
aimerait bien sûr mieux les voir rouler
sur les sur les rails
on ne fait pas ça non plus pour j'espère
un petit peu mes mots mais bon on est
votre vie c'est pas facile
non mais je commence une petite chose
qu'est ce que vous répondez quand on
vous dit que vous n'êtes plus
actuellement au service du public
je trouve ça vraiment dommage parce que
c'est vrai que le train on le sait très
bien plus populaire qu'il ne l'est en
fait on se rend bien compte tous les
jours que les gens ne peuvent pas
prendre le train
comme ça si facilement ce qui vous dise
madame que finalement bon huit jours de
grève on ne touche pas votre régime
spécifique de retraite
il n'est plus question de supprimer un
certain nombre de lignes mais il faut
tout de même être un petit peu plus
performant pour rembourser la dette
vous dites pas après tout c'est quand
même quelque chose que nous pourrions
faire non faut rester en l'état
non pas du tout de toute façon tout ce
que vous dites pour l'instant on en a
pas du tout la certitude on nous a pas
dit qu'on n'avait pas supprimer 6000
kilomètres de voies et on nous a pas dit
non plus quel serait notre retraite
enfin combien on toucherait quand on
aurait 50 ans ou 55 ans ou même si fera
pas qu'on travaille jusqu'à 60 ans pour
l'instant on n'a aucune certitude
puisque le plan n'est pas débattue pour
l'instant à ce que je sache le ministre
des transports et et notre président ne
veut pas parler avec nos représentants
syndicaux au moins sur la retraite y est
en principe d'une commission qui a
maintenant quatre mois pour étudier les
régimes spéciaux et en l'occurrence le
vôtre il a quatre mois pour décider mais
pour l'instant nous on ne sait pas du
tout si dans quatre mois on nous dira
pas la même chose qu'aujourd'hui en fait
puisqu'il n'y a pas de discours
actuellement puisqu'il ya passé pas
ouvert le débat
oui visiblement il ya un manque de
communication c'est moins confuse et on
va essayer d'y remédier on va maintenant
à un dépôt de la ratp fr robert villiers
et leur vivier
oui mais si on vous représentez vous
bonsoir plus exactement
bonsoir bien alors vous êtes en retraite
à la ratp l'un aussi pour vos régimes de
retraite et puis d'une manière
d'attendre et en grève pardon pour vos
régimes de retraite et et puis d'une
manière plus générale contre le projet
de réforme de la sécurité sociale alors
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à vous
montrer solidaire des gens de la sncf
monsieur aulas sait pas il n'y a pas que
la solidarité
bah ça fait suite à tous que tout ce
qu'on subit depuis quelques années les
salaires qui sont bloqués les
les mauvaises conditions de travail le
manque le manque de personnel et la ratp
tout ça tout ça depuis des années ont
suivi leur maintenant on s'attaque à
notre régime de retraite
voilà c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase maintenant nous on
continuera le mouvement est ce que vous
pensez monsieur quand même de même que
ddd des personnels de la fonction
publique comme vous la ratp vous devez
pas faire comme les autres français un
effort par exemple les salariés du privé
ont accepté 40 ans et cetera et cetera
je vais vous surprendre un petit peu
monsieur moi je suis d'accord avec juppé
je suis d'accord avec juppéiste hors
essence
égalité de traitement entre le privé et
le public et donc les 37 annuités et
demie ben pour le privé pour public et
le privé n'est plus à 30 cette année mis
en principe il est déjà à quarante
années
ce n'est pas malheureusement pour eux
mais on l'espère honnêtement que le
mouvement va se durcir se durcir et
connaît que les gars du privé viennent
nous rejoindre
bien alors absolument demeurer tout
c'est toutes ces manoeuvres du candidat
chirac dans la campagne électorale était
là mais on va tracer moins cinq ans et
tout le monde de tout ça merci monsieur
merci monsieur vous retrouver tout à
l'heure je voudrais qu'on aille
maintenant on verra un autre
syndicaliste un syndicat qui a une
position à part dans ce dans ce conflit
à savoir la cfdt enfin jusqu'à présent
du moins monsieur je pète vous êtes
numéro deux de la cfdt vous êtes en
direct avec nous de clermont ferrand
alors qu'en est il de la position d'une
certaine façon solitaire certains disent
courageuse de la cfdt dans dans ce
conflit qui est il faut tout de même une
réforme de la sécurité sociale dans
notre position n'est ni courageuse mais
les confronter aux réalités
je crois que je suis stupéfait content
dit qu'il ne fallait rien changé à la
sécurité sociale
égouttez loire nous avons le système de
santé qui est un des plus chers du monde
et qu'ils remboursent le moins quand on
n'a pas une mutuelle et en même temps
c'est tout petits de la cohésion de la
société française lui même exclu près de
1 million de paires
est ce que c'est un discours qui passe
bien près de militants sur le terrain
samedi
mais attendez le problème c'est d'abord
il faut rien rétablir la vérité et je
crois que la sécurité sociale avait
besoin d'une réforme en profondeur
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle est financée
d'une manière injuste c'est 80% du
financement c'est les salariés qu'ils
payent donc il faut élargir son
financement
2 c'est un système où la part dit
patronale repose trop sur les salaires
et qui donc qui crée du chômage et c'est
un système qui n'est pas du tout régulé
dit autrement c'est vraiment la sécu une
planche à billets c'est la banque de
tous les prescripteurs et les médias y
compris monsieur smet il faut allonger
la durée de cotisation
je viens sur les cotisations les
cotisations et dernier point
quand j'entends parler de rap de la
sécurité sociale d'étatisation de la
sécurité sociale est ce que disait
monsieur blonde c'est ce que disait
monsieur blondel
il est bien placé pour le savoir alors
non il est bien placé pour ça va je lui
dire pourquoi
aujourd'hui et depuis 1967 les
ordonnances c'est le gouvernement qui
décide des recettes et des dépenses de
la sécurité sociale
ça n'a jamais été un conseil
d'administration d'une caisse quelconque
est le seul conseil d'administration qui
pouvait décider de l' équilibre
financier si la branche maladie est
depuis 28 ans elle a jamais pris ses
décisions
monsieur mois sera alors maintenant je
vais vous dire des rues attendez vous
avez l'occasion de revenir un instant
jour éclairant intime allait poser une
question sur les retraites voulez vous y
répondre eh ben je vous ai y répond dans
un instant vous assure on va revenir à
vous je vais faire un petit tour
d'horizon maintenant pour maintenir dans
notre conversation assez détendu avec
nos amis politiques qui sont ici pierre
lellouche au nom du rpr alors vous avez
opiné un certain nombre de
chauzy par monsieur monsieur se mettre
certainement mais si je peux répondre en
rafale est très rare ici à monsieur
blondel d'abord mais avec tout le
respect que je lui dois je suis étonné
qu'ils disent que nous voulions mettre
fin au principe de la sécurité sociale
ce que le gouvernement essaye de faire
c'est de la sauver la sécurité sociale
parce qu'on ne peut plus on ne peut plus
avoir un régime avec les lacunes qui
viennent d'être dit qui en plus est de
déficit ne transportent un déficit
d'environ 60 milliards de francs par an
à moins d'avoir un système complètement
déficitaire et de le laisser à nos
enfants comme ça avec une dette de plus
en plus énormes ça système qui ne
fonctionne pas premier pot je voudrais
dire aussi à monsieur duteil de la cgt
qui a parlé d des retraites des
cheminots et qui ensuite parlé d'un
service public menacé une chose le
service public c'est le service d'abord
du public
en échange les contraintes de service
public les employés de l'état ou des
entreprises publiques honte un avantage
considérable par rapport à tous les
autres ils ont la sécurité de l'emploi à
vie ce qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui c'est qu'au nom du service
public
on essaye de faire avaler à l'ensemble
de l'opinion publique française la
pilule qu'il faut défendre des statuts
particuliers dont certains datent depuis
très longtemps du 19e siècle de l'époque
de la bête humaine et des mythes et
d'emile zola pour la sncf
on essaye de faire avaler aux gens
l'idée que au nom du service public
il est normal que des gens s'arrêtent de
travailler à 50 ans et il est normal que
cette retraite à 50 ans soit financé à
50% par les contribuables la vraie
question elle est la leçon que nous nous
ne nous ne disons même pas qu'il faut
annuler les régimes spéciaux nous disons
il faut les remettre à plat une
commission a été non je termine si vous
permettez sur ce point parce que tout
est mélangé cette dame de la sncf disait
mais nous on est en grève à cause des
retraites
eh bien les retraites ne sont pas dans
le plan ni de la sécurité sociale ni
dans le volant de la sncf justement
mission qui vient d'être installé et qui
doit donner
recommandations dans quatre mois
commentant la nation ensuite on engage
des négociations ça n'est pas si les
jeunes ne sont pas dans le plan mais il
ya une commission qui va s'en occuper
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya de
toute évidence une entreprise à tout cas
il ya manipulation mais tout cela deux
mélanges savants entre l'université les
cheminots la la ratp le régime de
sécurité sociale le pays s'arrête et
personne ne comprend alors madame du
mans vous pouvez réagir et après je ne
m'en avait accouché à nicole borvo leur
avis madame dumas en voulait madame du
vent je vous appelle mes animaux mais
j'ai pas retenu votre a dit effet pascal
non mais lâché un petit peu scandalisé
il n'y a pas que les retraites qui font
que qu'on est ici en grève il ya tout un
contrat de plan sur l'avenir de la sncf
vient du contrat que l'on va en parler
mais paraît si madame bernard kouchner
d je crois qu'il ya eu un grand
acharnement dans la brutalité qui est
responsable de cette succession de
propositions voire d'imposition au
moment où un début de dialogue
s'amorçait c'est quand même le
gouvernement qui est responsable de
cette confusion
c'est à dire retraite sncf plan de la
sncf blanc pour la réforme de la
sécurité sociale c'est un calendrier
insupportable on dirait vraiment qu'ils
prennent des cours du soir pour prendre
les gens pour des imbéciles
on a commencé à débattre et à ce moment
là avec brutalité encore une fois on
plonge le pays dans une atmosphère très
curieux là aussi un gérant de
communication vous écoutez à ce niveau
méthodologique à ce niveau ça devient de
l'art ya peut-être un retard d'exécution
jeu peut-être peut-être mais tout ça on
ne veut le dire on fait une chose à la
fois dense payer c'est difficile à
expliquer pourquoi n'avez vous pas fait
cette émission avant c'était
indispensable c'est compliqué le régime
d'assurance maladie ça fait longtemps
qu'on dit que ça marche pas si on nous
avait dit ça encore une idée aussi mal
on l'aurait fait avant nous on l'a fait
comme on chante ça aussi parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on débat est maintenant aux
débats des lois au moment où il ya une
tension est quasi avec ce qui vient de
se passer maintenant l'appel au comité
des usagers
on est bientôt comité de défense de la
république une atmosphère de tensions
voire d' espèce de fausse guerre civile
tout à fait dangereuse et tout à fait de
la rétention aussi du côté des syndicats
on va peut-être faire un petit tour chez
monsieur de le halage états unis c'est
bon bien sûr à la cftc c'est l'autre
tout le monde ce soir à monsieur
monsieur de la cftc qui l'a aussi n'a
pas tout à fait la même position et bien
évidemment que la cgt et même que le
ciel d'été de ce 2e alors votre votre
situation ce soir vous vous d'un côté
vous dites vous ce déferlement de grèves
successives vous fait peur et d'un autre
côté vous dites au gouvernement il faut
absolument qu'on se réunisse tout de
suite sinon ça va mal tourner moi je
crois effectivement qu'il est important
aujourd'hui de regarder le problème du
point de vue des salariés des salariés
en grève et des salariés qui ne sont pas
en grève et qui en subissent bien sûr
les conséquences
je crois aussi qu'il faut se placer du
point de vue des familles des retraités
qui subissent aussi les conséquences de
ces grèves et moi j'ai envie de dire ce
soir ça suffit ça suffit
parce que le but n'est pas de mettre le
pays en panne totale
le but c'est de sortir de la crise et il
y à un premier problème qui se pose il
est devant sur le devant de la scène ces
jolies de la sncf et des cheminots fois
qu il est bien clair aujourd'hui que si
le gouvernement ne ne se décide pas à
ouvrir vraiment le dialogue avec les
cheminots encore aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
fonctionné
je crois que nous allons vers les
difficultés majeures
il faut que le gouvernement accepte le
dialogue avec les cheminots et nous nous
pensons que la meilleure formule
aujourd'hui c'est la mise en place d'un
médiateur
s'il n'y a pas de médiateur ministre à
grasse par monsieur 2
monsieur le ministre des transports a
discuté toute la gent il faut encore un
médiateur en plus non mais bien entendu
ça ne marche pas il n'y a pas de
dialogue efficace actuellement la sncf
monsieur pons lui même a reçu les
syndicats s'en faire d'ouverture moi je
crois que si on veut traiter les
conflits de façon moderne pour éviter
des grèves durable il faut accepter
l'intervention d'un médiateur qui permet
de débloquer de dénouer les fans et de
la communication vers la solution la
communication directement du
gouvernement et puis là les salariés ne
passe plus selon vous je voudrais
insister sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui si
le président a public
et si monsieur juppé et si monsieur
juppé ne se décide pas à réunir
rapidement les syndicats pour engager un
vrai dialogue et pour donner un vrai
coup de départ à négociations moi je
crains le pire pour la semaine prochaine
merci monsieur de le nous allons aller à
au centre de tri postal de strasbourg là
aussi vous savez que la poste a rejoint
le mouvement depuis peu nous sommes à
strasbourg présentez vous avant de vous
exprimer et dit un petit peu par rapport
à tout ce qui vient d'être dit ce qui
vous motive ou dans ce mouvement
georges jean françois van est président
national de la cftc des ptt
je suis venu apporter mon soutien à mes
collègues en grève
nous mettons pas en cause la nécessité
d'un plan global de sauvegarde de la
protection sociale
mais avec la mise en cause de notre
régime de retraites le gouvernement a
fait exploser le ras-le-bol ras-le-bol
sur quoi ras-le-bol de voir se
poursuivre les suppressions d'emplois
alors qu'il ya trois millions de
chômeurs ici au centre de tri de
strasbourg ces cinq mille paquets
supplémentaires qui sont à traiter tous
les jours et sans moyens supplémentaires
ras-le-bol aussi devoir recruter des
collègues sur des situations précaires
par exemple des vacations de trois
heures à 6 heures du matin alors nous
disons effectivement au gouvernement il
est temps d'ouvrir des négociations sur
toutes les conditions de travail les
restructurations et ne pas mettre en
cause de régimes de retraite qui t'as
quand j'entends je récuse ans que la
poste et télécommunication monsieur
fillon
depuis les etats unis nous dire le
calendrier de privatisation de france
télécom
je dis que c'est la preuve de la
provocation et que l'inde il y aura
encore plus de postiers de télé
communiqué de la grève
merci à monsieur donc on continue notre
tour d'horizon politique avec vous
madame borvo vous représentez ici
le parti communiste vous avez entendu un
certain nombre de choses
bien sûr je crois qu'il s'agit pas
simplement d'un problème de
communication c'est une question des
questions de fond et je crois que le
gouvernement ou à entendre ce que disent
les salariés et on peut dire dans leur
ensemble parce que je crois qu'il est
très dangereux d'opposer les salariés et
les usagers les usagers sont et salariés
les salariés sont des usagers et toutes
les sondages toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion qui ont été faites ces temps
ci montre que très très majoritairement
les français dans leur ensemble
soutiennent les mouvements à l'heure
actuelle même si ça occasionne ont des
gènes
oui dans un premier temps et moi je
rencontre des gens qui marchent dans la
rue et qui sont très mécontents de
marché qui sont autant beaucoup de
problèmes des femmes en particulier
mais il n'empêche qu'ils trouvent qu'ils
ont raison parce que ça suffit
alors qu'il n'en permettait
qu'irresponsable le plan juppé sur la
protection sociale
il est massivement rejeté 65 % des gens
disent que c'est toujours les mêmes qui
vont payer alors le gouvernement voir
retirer son plan est ensuite discuté je
trouve qu'il est très dangereux au site
opposées d'un côté des
beast et de l'autre côté les les
réformateurs je crois le problème c'est
qu'elle préformes 1 c'était envie de
bouger ça on ne verra pas là à les voir
monsieur de robien qui était président
du groupe udf qui se trouve en duplex à
amiens monsieur devront bien bonsoir
bonsoir
alors c'est ce blocage apparent de la
société qu'est ce que comment est ce que
vous à l'udf ou l'analyser comment est
ce que vous comptez y répondre je crois
que c'est vraiment un énorme malentendu
on voit qu'il y a d'une part des
étudiants qui pour des raisons de
confort matériel qu'on comprend bien et
aussi d'appréhension sur l'avenir
malheureusement sont obligés de
manifester de défiler pour essayer
d'obtenir de nouveaux moyens pour
l'enseignement supérieur c'est une chose
et puis il ya le problème de la
protection sociale et la protection
sociale c'est quelque chose de sérieux
et c'est quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
traiter à la légère j'allais dire la
droite contre la gauche ou la gauche
contre la droite où les syndicats avec
des idées toutes faites
alors que ces syndicats disaient dans le
secret des cabinets ministériels qu'ils
étaient d'accord en grande partie sur
les mesures proposées par monsieur juppé
la semaine dernière alors j'ai envie de
dire tout simplement
il est grand temps de dédramatiser et il
est grand temps aussi de séparer un peu
les problèmes
la restructuration de la sncf peut-être
qu'on peut voir ça dans un mois deux
mois trois mois
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est d'une part
le problème des étudiants parce qu'ils
sont légitimement inquiets et faisons
effectivement une grande négociation
une grande table ronde pour voir comment
on peut mieux préparer leur avenir
et deuxièmement sauvons la protection
sociale parce que tous les français y
sont attachés qu'ils aient voté ou pas
la confiance à monsieur juppé et on sait
très bien que si on veut sauver la
protection sociale il faudra tous qu'on
fasse des efforts les uns vers les
autres et qu'on ne se bloque pas dans
des systèmes que dénonçait d'ailleurs
par monsieur kouchner un instant il a il
est dit textuellement on sait que ça ne
marche pas depuis des années lors si ça
ne marche pas depuis des années pourquoi
depuis des années on ne s'est pas mis
autour d'une table ensemble pour voir
comment ça pourrait marcher formation de
revient il ya vous signez les quais
monsieur barreau qui nous écoutent et
qui sera donc qui nous rejoindra sans
doute à la fin de cette émission on va
faire un tour quand même sur un autre
conflit important qui a démarré
ces conflits d'ailleurs qui est celui
des étudiants nous allons aller à
toulouse vous savez que toulouse est une
faculté très très présente dans ce
conflit depuis le début bonsoir à
toulouse je suppose que vous nous
entendez
nous sommes donc devant la faculté je
crois que nous n'avons pas pu rentrer à
l'intérieur on est dedans on est dedans
grâce à la gentillesse du président de
l'université paul sabatier bien alors
donc ce soir là vous êtes non pas au
huitième jour de la grève pour ce qui
concerne les universités mais presse qu
à la fin de la deuxième semaine c'est ça
non même même beaucoup plus puisque on
entame le 22e jour de grève consécutif
gravi libyen alors présenté vous et
dites nous où on est votre détermination
ce soir dans dans ce conflit qui est en
parallèle avec les autres ceux de la
fonction publique je m'appelle guy
monier je suis en licence de mécanique
et membre de la cordée sont des
étudiants de toulouse où on en est
actuellement ben je crois que c'est bien
simple le mouvement il a commencé déjà
depuis deux mois
ça fait trois semaines que on entame la
quatrième semaine de grève illimitée où
on en est on a reconduit la grève
jusqu'à lundi
ce que l'on attend et d'un canton
demander pourquoi on ne s'est pas mis
plus tôt devant devant pourquoi on s'est
pas assis devant une table devant le
ministre pour discuter
ça fait deux mois que l'on demande ça et
ça fait deux mois qu'on a rien alors
bernard kouchner donc vous avez là on a
fait un tour d'horizon complet tous les
problèmes mais ils sont multiples la
fonction publique étudiants oui et puis
ça se complique parce qu'il y aura
d'autres
c'est à dire que on est perplexe devant
l'ensemble de ces problèmes qui arrivent
en même temps et je pense qu'il ya eu
manifestement au moins une erreur de
calendrier et un ton qui n'était pas
supportable
alors que faire maintenant c'est la
question que vous posez est-ce qu'on
peut traiter tous ces problèmes à la
fois je disais tout à l'heure on peut en
traiter 1
ce sont des problèmes sérieux qui existe
depuis longtemps le prime de la
protection sociale de l'assurance
maladie est un problème on lui même
on n'y a pas assez réfléchi mais des tas
de gens y ont réfléchi mais il faut du
temps moi j'avais proposé un référendum
on y viendra peut-être mais un
référendum pas comme ça une journée un
an de débats dans ce pays pour savoir
quelles réformes nécessaires pour que
non pas démanteler l'assurance maladie
non pas l'état teasé parce que c'est
déjà fait mais au contraire pour
maintenir ce qui est essentiel
égalité de tous devant les moyens
d'acheter son latin qui devra contenir
pendant ce temps là qu'est ce que ce
principe soit il fallait il faut pour à
l'aise et je crois que tout le monde va
le proposer maintenant qu'il ya une
brutalité 0 on arrête un petit peu et
puis qu'on commence à parler
attendez je voudrais pas me faire
l'avocat du diable mais la force de
brutaliser personnes dans ce pays
non mais maintenant ça va venir vous
allez voir on arrête ou alors on sait
que de grève
promise comme générale mardi puis le 17
et c'est vraiment ça va glisser vers le
pire alors n'attendons pas ça on a voulu
réfléchir
en général ces problèmes dans l'urgence
à chaud dit on sait sociologiquement et
historiquement frais je crois qu'on
pourrait démontrer le contraire une fois
mais c'est mal parti
bien alors ce jeu bourdelle et pierre
lellouche ensuite
et pendant ce temps là monsieur jacques
barrot mini affaires sociales et du
travail est en train de s'installer nous
écoutent attentivement alors monsieur
blondel vous nous avez écouté là pendant
une dizaine de minutes
oui je dois vous dire d'ailleurs que les
conditions de travail sont un peu
particulière parce que de mon bureau
j'ai sursauté quelques fois alors je
voudrais m'inscrire en faux notamment
monsieur de robien a beaucoup insisté
il a même laissé entendre qu'il y avait
des acquiescements dans les cabinets
ministériels et bien je vais apprendre
quelque chose à monsieur de robien et à
tous les députés qui sont là c'est que
le plan qui a été présenté au parlement
n'est pas les discussions que nous avons
eues on a fait un effet de surprise
et pourquoi et bien pour essayer
d'obtenir la baisse des taux d'intérêt
on n'a pas compté avec justement la
représentation des organisations
syndicales
on n'a pas concilier avec elle on n'a
pas discuté avec elle mais on a fait une
décision brutale pour essayer d'avoir un
effet qui est un problème économique et
financier à partir de ce moment là il ne
peut plus y avoir de dix jours a pris
tout ce que vous avez reçu même permis
monsieur oui de dire qu'on m'avait menti
par homme sur six ans que j'ai vous
n'aurez pas permis de le dire si ça
n'était pas vrai maintenant je voudrais
dire à monsieur le député
c'est curieux les fonctionnaires ne vont
plus avoir la garantie de leur retraite
puisque avant elle était assurée par eux
ce qu'on appelle le grand livre de la
dette de l'état de la dette publique
comment se fait-il que les députés eux
gardent cette garantie est ce que si on
doit tous faire des sacrifices on ne
devrait pas
à commencer par cela je m'excuse il ya
des moments où il faut effectivement
dire les choses comme elles sont enfin
lorsqu'il fait cadeau tout de suite fait
cadeau tout de suite ma retraite je suis
lucide j'ai fait ma carrière je donne
mes annuités de retraite tout de suite
ça va vous faire débat oui je vais vous
rappeler monsieur bombe blonde est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles la force
ouvrière elle est tellement hostile à ce
projet qui je le rappelle a été approuvé
par l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale par l'ensemble de la presse
par l'ensemble des observateurs y
compris de gauche y compris monsieur
kouchner qui est en face de moi dans un
article ce matin encore y compris par
l'ensemble des français qui en général
ça que ce que ce système a besoin d'être
revue et ce système est juste et les
moins favorisés le docteur engage les
moins favorisés une perez la médiation
ce n'est pas sa réponse n est donc pas
vous êtes content monsieur le problème
de parce que ce n'est pas seulement vous
étiez le principal gagnant du système
précédent
alors je galère de rien du tout monsieur
qu'est ce que c'est que ce monsieur jean
d'affirmations entendez je vous explique
je suis gagnant de rien du tout j'avais
tout s'il s'agit d'ennemis limite au cdh
est habilité dits spéciaux mais si vous
chercher en permanence à chaque séance
de conseil d'administration vous parlez
d'un pactole à londres avec toi c'est de
la diffamation au monsieur qui m'ont
attaqué sur sa retraite alors pas de
l'histoire met en bouche de saillé
passion il ya de l'histoire
depuis josé pas diffamer monsieur 145
juste un mini été mis en place en 1945
était un système qui était confiée en
fait d'eux des entreprises des
organismes privés dont les syndicats le
système malheureusement et de haies et
le patronat le système est devenu
déficitaire de plus en plus au fil des
années aujourd'hui ça se montra 2400
milliards de francs c'est à dire bien
davantage que le budget de l'état et où
il est donc normal il est donc normal
que la représentation nationale de
droite ou de gauche soit eux soit obligé
de se pencher cet agent public
argentan dire que c'est la femme lassée
social monsieur blondel et ensuite ça
arrive qu'on l'a dit mais moi je pense
que c'est une grosse équipe championne
agir mieux un budget de 15 100 milliards
avec un déficit de 2 285 ou est-ce que
c'est mieux géré que la protection
sociale collective qui dépasse 2 mille
milliards et j'indique que ce sont à 75%
les cotisations des gens monsieur non
pas sur les salaires voilà c'est un
prélèvement sur les entreprises c'est
une petite nation ce sport vous n'êtes
jamais avoir autres réponses d'abord
monsieur kouchner un monsieur blondel
est ce que l'état s'occupera mieux de la
sécurité sociale il ya un problème de
fond est un problème de méthode je les
dis y'a une réponse oui mais la réponse
est que bien entendu il fallait réformer
ce système
je le dis avec beaucoup de simplicité
mais pas comme on l'a fait là pas en
imposer sur le feng oui mais attendez
sur le fond dans parlons-en un tout
petit peu parce que les gens comprennent
pas ils ont l'impression qu'on leur
pique leurs systèmes
ils ont l'impression que ce qui est l
identité européenne et française par
excellence
et bien c'est justement ce qui va
disparaître attendez attendez il y avait
un trou de la sécurité sociale
je vous ai comme si un bateau avait eu
au fond et qu'on se contentait d'écoper
monsieur on invente un système de
régulation nécessaires pour réformer et
moderniser que ça marche je suis
l'auteur du problème on est au coeur de
la réforme de la sécurité sociale et des
retraites monsieur barreaux et en duplex
avec nous monsieur barreaux on parle
beaucoup de vous et de votre réforme si
je puis dire oui vous avez vu que la
discussion était assez vite me sourit
mais je sais pas j'entends bernard
kouchner qui dit à juste titre qu'il
faut réformer
il al'air d'émettre des doutes sur la
méthode mais moi je veux dire que
financier
ce que nous faisons tout ce que nous
faisons nous le faisons en ayant écouté
avec les forums que j'en ai animé un
certain nombre après avoir écouté
beaucoup les partenaires sociaux et il y
a d'ailleurs parmi ses partenaires
sociaux des gens qui admettent que dans
cette réforme il y a des repères positif
alors bien sûr tout n'est pas encore
complètement bouclé écrit il y a encore
dialogue je le répète mais il ya des
moments où un grand pays comme la france
ne peut pas constamment différer la
réforme qu'il faut faire leur garantir
la mener mathieu barrau puisque vous
êtes avec nous on va peut-être prendre
un certain nombre de questions mais
d'abord voudrais vous poser une question
oui moi je voudrais dire à écouter le
projet vous avez présenté manifestement
ne convient pas donc qu'est ce que vous
allez faire retirer ce projet et ensuite
le débat est possible je vais vous
rappelez vous dites il faut il faut
faire quelque chose il ya une dette mais
qui est responsable du bien cette dette
il faut savoir que si aussi prenez
autrement effectivement pour répondre
aux problèmes peut-être qu'il y en
aurait moins par exemple au lieu de de
créer un impôt supplémentaire si on
faisait cotiser les revenus financiers
au même taux que les salariés ça ferait
tout de suite 70 milliards par exemple
réponse ce samedi nous retournerons au
moment où la sncf a déjà en faire une
une à la fois allez monsieur j'ai abordé
ramadam borvo que quand on a des dettes
on peut pas ne pas un jour les payer la
solidarité ne peut pas constamment être
assurés à crédit et on a essayé de
trouver un système très juste et je vais
lui dire que dans ce fameux rds le
remboursement de la dette sociale
on demande beaucoup plus qu'on n'avait
jamais demandé aux possesseurs de
revenus du patrimoine et du capital et 3
ans s'il est bien de votre prénom de 53
je veux lui dire je les écoutais alors
je veux qu elle m'écoute je veux lui
dire aussi que l'on se donne les moyens
les uns et les autres d'éviter des
gaspillages pour éviter le retour des
déficits et pour soigner mieux car il
s'agit monsieur de dépenser mieux pour
soigner mieux monsieur barreau quand on
est costaud pour les changes
du temps avant de avant de réformer à ce
que vous dites que monsieur kouchner par
exemple qui vaut mieux arrêter puisque
le message ne reste pas sans lesquelles
il faut parler je pose de questions si
vous permettez à monsieur jacques barrot
un résident rapide la cg que vous
évoquez même si elle un autre nom
maintenant elle est passée alors qu'il
n'y avait pas la majorité dont vous
disposez après concertation et avec un
accord général comment ça se fait il y
avait il une méthode magique
deuxième question connaissez mieux la
réponse encore madame veil a réformé les
retraites dans le gouvernement précédent
il n'y a pas eu sept explosions ça avait
été préparé par le livre blanc
le monsieur claude evin est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une méthode qui vous échappe
monsieur barreau berlin genève bernard
kouchner répond je réponds sur le
premier point il s'agit de rembourser
une tête
nous avons veillé à ce que ça soit fait
de la manière la plus équitable possible
en essayant de faire mieux que cette cg
que vous que vous évoquez en essayant de
faire dans l'assiette de la csg y ait
plus de revenus précisément ce réseau
large deuxième réponse bernard kouchner
oui pour les régimes spéciaux enfin il
n'y a aucune décision de prise c'est le
vert avec une série de avec un groupe de
personnes très compétentes très
qualifiées et indépendantes qui vont
faire des propositions enfin qu'est ce
que c'est que cette désinformation slim
c'est bien la méthode qui a été utilisée
précédent d'information l'arrêt par l'un
des agents pression à ses chances bien
monsieur barreaux on va pas faire donner
on va essayer attendez je ne l'aide pas
je voudrais éclairer le débat comment se
fait-il que dans l'attraction téléchargé
je voudrais dire que je voudrais j'ai
une question à poser le subaru mais
d'abord je voudrais si vous l'acceptez
monsieur le ministre que nous
retournions au moment où il y a des
cheminots la sncf qui ont une question
précise à vous poser allez-y puisqu'on
garde le dialogue via logo wii alors
dialoguant
c'est rémy croissant donc je suis agent
de conduite aux dépôts du mans et c'est
vrai que c'est difficile d'intervenir
mais je trouve que quand même on a à
faire un débat de spécialistes sur le
plateau ou plutôt d'hommes politiciens
allez je voudrais déjà dire une première
remarque à monsieur barreau lorsque les
hommes politiques monsieur d'accord je
vais essayer d'être à pitre monsieur
monsieur barreau a dit qu'il avait
engagée dans ces forums d'un large débat
je crois savoir qu à limoges au moins il
a viré la cgt du débat qu'il avait
normalement qu'il avait prévu quoi il la
cgt a été exclue de ce débat un vrai
dialogue juger par les parties pour leur
nom pour le moins pour le moins deuxième
question je tenais à monsieur kouchner
je trouve que monsieur kouchner ne
devrait quand même pas trop se féliciter
de voir aujourd'hui la droite s'appuyer
sur des mesures que
le gouvernement précédent auquel il
appartenait à plus se servir notamment
sur le livre blanc de michel rocard il
s'en sert et la csg
aujourd'hui a été multi presque
multiplié par balladur et puis demain va
encore s'élargir
je trouve que pour un gouvernement qui
visait de gauche après le monsieur kalt
kouchner appartenait il devrait quand
même pas trop s'en féliciter pour le
moins d'intérêt de gauche sont des
déficits quand même je voudrais il n'y a
pas donné on va les sites à l'heure mais
ses autres collègues que vous à la ratp
poser une question est de savoir
maintenant et plus du prêt pour ce
monsieur barreau qu'est ce que vous
dites en table de dialogue qu'est ce que
vous répondez aux gens qui sont dans la
rue aujourd'hui comment arrêter cette
histoire et moi je voudrais que les gens
posent des questions notre concitoyen
cheminots ne m'a pas vraiment posé de
questions il m'a fait en quelque sorte
nous a fait un procès moi je veux
répondre aux questions parce que je suis
convaincu que quand on répand et que les
gens sont de bonne foi et bien ceux qui
savent et passion atp au dépôt
d'aubervilliers s'ils voulaient bien
monsieur barroso on va s'y rendre tout
de suite puisque là aussi à l'air atp
les questions qui se posent alors une
vraie question
allez-y monsieur oui bonjour monsieur le
ministre
ribes avec machinistes receveur la ratp
au dépôt d'aubervilliers
posez votre question comme on dit dans
les jeux oui j'aimerais demander à
monsieur barreaux où est le dialogue
rien n'est fixé pourquoi la mission de
la commission le verse à laquelle la
ratp va participer la mission de cette
commission c'est étudier la mise en
place des 40 annuités à la ratp donc
d'ores et déjà dans l'intitulé on se
rend compte que tout est fixé décidé d'
avance bien répond et le dialogue
je suis très claire et très nette la
commission le vert à seulement pour
objectif de regarder comment on peut
consolider l'avenir de ces régions et le
problème de la durée de cotisation est
un élément parmi d'autres et il est
clair que la commission le vert travail
en toute liberté et j'incite beaucoup
les responsables la ratp et monsieur qui
vient de me poser la question à aller
devant la commission le vert car je suis
convaincue en effet qu'il y a des
spécificités
on ne peut pas traiter des régimes
spéciaux comme du régime général c'est
pas vrai et nous allons nous donner le
temps
j'ajoute que quand le vert or a fini son
travail et bien il y aura encore des
consultations et on verra ensuite
comment de faire un projet de loi donc
rien n'est décidé la france est
totalement irrationnelle ce soir rien
n'est décidé dans ce domaine et voilà
qu'on ne peut même pas ouvrir le dossier
tout le monde a peur monsieur barreau
donc selon vous donc rien n'est décidé
dans ce domaine là un conflit qui vous
concerne moins c'est celui des étudiants
à toulouse là aussi elle est question
qui se pose sur les étudiants puisqu'ils
n'ont pas eu visiblement réponses à
leurs interrogations notamment sur
l'aide matérielle qu'ils attendent pour
sauver entre guillemets leur université
question alors bon je m'appelle en auge
fusionnant architecture et si je vais
poser une question aujourd'hui à un
monsieur barreau qui est le ministre de
l'emploi du travail pardon c'est en tant
que travailleurs en formation et donc je
vais vous demander monsieur barreaux est
ce que vous pouvez apporter des
solutions concrètes au chômage autre que
ce qui a été fait par le gouvernement
jusqu'à présent autre que le racisme et
les charters de deux prêts autre que le
sexisme et le retour au foyer prônée par
codaccioni autre que la précarité par le
biais des ses yeux et autres sous-emploi
et bien arnaud j'essaye je suis pas tout
seul a à faire en sorte que les jeunes
puissent entrer plus vite dans les
entreprises qu'ils puissent
effectivement trouvé du travail à la
sortie de leurs études
et tout ça arnaud il faut aussi que ça
marche dans ce pays il faut pas que les
uns gaspille sans avoir le sens des
responsabilités puisque les autres les
jeunes par exemple
ben il attendait piétinent devant la
société parce que la génération qui a
disons un certain confort le confort des
situations acquises ne pense pas la
jeune génération
c'est pour ça que dans ce mouvement
d'aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose qui va
pas parce que tout est à ceux qui ont le
confort la situation acquise
et puis à vous les jeunes qui vite
quelle va être notre avenir
et bien moi je prétends que ce que nous
essayons de faire c'est de préparer
votre avenir en demandant quelques
efforts aujourd'hui
alors ça il n'est pas parmi des
étudiants mais il est avec nous ce soir
c'est monsieur blondel monsieur blondel
est ce que vous avez je suppose une
question à poser à monsieur barreaux
howie jeu
une monsieur le ministre pardonnez moi
il va être 22 heures j'attends une
lettre en réponse à la lettre que
j'avais adressée à monsieur le premier
ministre posant des questions précises
sur la sécurité sociale et surtout
évitant d'opposer les générations où les
catégories de salariés
oui mais tu es nou lé là je vous en suis
secourir monsieur blondel vous faites de
tissus à une lettre mettez nous dans le
coup parce que là on ne sait pas de quoi
il s'agit pas monsieur
cette lettre est importante dans la
limite où je posais toutes les questions
de principe que pose la réforme de la
sécurité sociale qui je le confirme a
été présenté comme un effet de surprise
et je posais notamment et bien le fait
de savoir très exactement comment
règlerait les problèmes de rationnement
puisque maintenant c'est le parlement
qui va vite c'est une enveloppe et
lorsque nous aurons dépassé cette
enveloppe pour sait pas ce qu'on va
faire je demandais comment deviendrait
le conseil de surveillance des députés
qui va venir à côté de la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie et de son
conseil d'administration
city qui sont des questions concernant
la fermeture de certains établissements
et organismes de sécurité sociale
monsieur se posaient des questions
concernant effectivement le débat le
prince à la roma dont je suis sûr c'est
pas si vous postez célèbre mais vous et
moi mais on sait pas si vous permettez
si bien d'une confiscation des 2000
milliards de la protection sociale
c'est que en principe on cacher on va
convoquer le congrès et il va falloir
donner compétence ou parlent autour
d'elles par modification monsieur
blondel ont arrêté là le premier tome de
de gaulle est au gouvernement on va
demander à monsieur barreau de répondre
monsieur baron répondait d'abord sur la
seconde marche on gèle la lettre est
bien arrivé et le premier ministre va
répondre incessamment mais je dois dire
que j'aime bien faire les choses
sérieusement et que je voulais que nous
préparions et premier ministre
évidemment mettra aussi sa marque dans
cette lettre des réponses qu'ils soient
des réponses précises les plus clair
possible pour dissiper des malentendus
et jeudi à marc blondel
mieux vaut que la lettre arrive quelques
heures plus tard et que ce soit une
taille pas le moindre élément à nous
deux à nos données sur le contrat
éventuel monsieur barreaux on excusera
que et le premier ministre va répondre à
marc blondel que l'étatisation de
sécurité sociale et bien non non ce
n'est pas du tout notre projet alors
roger c'est bien de laisser la sécurité
sociale aux mains des français
mais les français c'est aussi le
parlement c'est aussi les partenaires
sociaux chacun sa place
et si les responsabilités sont claires
il ya de la place pour chacun pour gérer
au mieux cette magnifique institution
que je reviens une question totalement
monsieur baroin laquelle je parle pas
l'impression que vous avez répondu
comment faire aujourd'hui jeu pour
essayer de calmer un peu le jeu ou de ou
de rétablir ce dialogue qui semble rompu
écoutez moi je suis vingt-quatre heures
sur vingt-quatre là pour expliquer les
choses à condition que l'on me pose des
questions qu'on veuille bien m'écouter
et je le dis très franchement je suis
très heureux ce soir de pouvoir dire
quelques mots regard 12 ans car nous
sommes là y'a rien à cacher moi je suis
engagé dans cette affaire difficile
parce que je pense que c'est une
question de voir si nous ne faisions pas
ce qu'il faut nous ne pouvons pas nous
ne pourrons pas préserver ce qui est de
meilleurs enfants question et
honnêtement ne laissons pas passer cette
occasion
et peur aujourd'hui l'emportent mais je
suis convaincu que si des gens veulent
se donner le temps de réfléchir et bien
nous pourrons rétablir question de
monsieur monsieur varone question des
questions mais juste avant une très
courte question de monsieur bernard
kouchner
est ce que monsieur barreau est d'accord
pour l'organisation d'un référendum en
prenant le top de la sécurité sociale
sur la protection sociale sur
l'assurance maladie
quel système de soins veulent les
français que sont ils prêts à payer quel
sacrifice pour préserver l'égalité des
soins parce que pardon tout à l'heure le
cheminot je lui ai mal répondu c'est
vrai qu'un déficit de gauche ça vaut un
déficit de droite faut le rembourser
mais ce qui ne vaut pas la même chose
c'est quand on augmente brutalement
comme on l'a fait en guise de dialogue
monsieur barul c'est très bien le
forfait hospitalier est là quand on a à
payer 70 francs par jour pour un enfant
dans une famille modeste c'est pas la
même chose que maintenant alors effet le
rire ou maintenir cela est ce que vous
êtes d'accord
quelqu un référendum qui prendrait le
temps de l'explication nécessaire dans
le pays puisque vous avez changement là
heureusement que nos journalistes ne
posons pas de questions ou si longue
monsieur marc os que d'accord sûr mais
soyons clairs le projet sur le sigle et
sociales a donné lieu à des débats il va
continuer au parlement puisque le
parlement doit habilité le gouvernement
mouiller on peut prendre aucune décision
si le parlement ne nous donne pas
l'habilitation donc on va en débattre et
je suis convaincu bernard kouchner que
ce que nous faisons n'est que dans la
continuité de ce qui a déjà été déjà
imaginé par vous et par un certain
nombre d'autres et moi même je peux
parler ce soir car lorsque la gauche
était au pouvoir je n'ai pas refusé
chaque fois qu'il s'agissait de mettre
un petit peu d'ordre dans la sécurité
sociale je n'ai pas refusé
d'une certaine manière de participer en
ayant moins un langage positif alors si
les jeunes ne peux pas croire que l'on
mélange la politique politicienne et la
sécurité sociale attendez monsieur
projetait aussi monsieur delarue qui est
là monsieur barroso est d'accord pour
continuer à répondre à quelques
questions comme ça à débattre avec des
invités qui sont ici sur le plateau
monsieur delarue alors les usagers des
coûts des choix des dessins pourtant qui
a été posé ses commentaires pour
décrisper la situation pour retrouver un
dialogue alors je vous pose la question
parce que pour l'instant on a des
espèces de petits bouts de réponse par
ci par là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire le
plus vite possible pour que le dialogue
soit réintroduit notamment la sncf la
ratp et ailleurs
avec les pouvoirs publics de manière à
faire en sorte que le conflit s'arrête
le plus vite possible
eh bien monsieur delarue il faut
expliquer expliquer toujours et dire
notamment que s'agissant des retraites
des cheminots
et bien non seulement aucune décision
n'est prise mais même si demain une
décision devait être prise à la suite
d'une loi à la suite de du travail de la
commission le vert et bien s'il ya des
adaptations du régime de retraite
elles sont pour ceux qui vont prendre
leur retraite dans 15 ans enfin tout le
monde sait bien que les adaptations sont
très progressive mais j'ajoute j'ajoute
que si le si le gouvernement avait voulu
tricher dans cette affaire il aurait dit
eh bien je demande
l'habilitation pour prendre des
ordonnances pour réformer les régimes de
retraite
il ne l'a pas fait les régimes spéciaux
les problèmes de retraite des cheminots
de la ratp et tous les autres car il y
avait bien d'autres régimes
et bien il ne l'a pas voulu puisqu'il a
confié commission le soin de réfléchir
on ouvre le dossier pour regarder un
petit peu de free press bovins mais
surtout il faut s'expliquer il faut
s'excuser ministre monsieur monsieur
delarue vous poser une question pour
demain après demain vous lui répondez à
long terme lui il voulait savoir comment
commandes allaient circuler demain après
demain lundi quoi habitants que ça mais
moi dans ce pays je ne peux pas croire
que un bon dialogue ne permettent pas un
moment donné de trouver je rappellerai
au moins une armistice
on laisse les choses se faire est ce que
le moment de la décision et bien le cas
échéant risque qui opposera est ce que
quand une décision n'est pas prise on
doit pas s'y opposer
qu'est-ce que vous est ce que vous
pensez monsieur barreau qu'on doit aller
jusqu'à je sais pas réquisitionner
l'armée comme certains le demandent au
rpr par exemple non écoutez franchement
expliquons-nous ans pour transporter les
gens expliquant nous entre français que
chacun essaye de comprendre ce qui se
passe ça veut pas dire qu'on sera tous
d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'on aura
relativiser des désaccords le
gouvernement n'est pas en train de
bouleverser les choses
il a un projet qui résonna
et que certaines personnalités qui
n'appartiennent pas la majorité ont
approuvé tout de même alors c'est pas
moi qui l'inventé
ça veut donc dire qu'il ya du bon sens
derrière moi je suis un homme du terrain
et jamais j'irai me m'engager
personnellement comme je le fais en ce
moment
six jeunes étaient convaincus de faire
un peu mon devoir que tout ne soit pas
parfait d'accord mais c'est perfectible
discutant dialogue mais à baroville
intervention monsieur 2e à la cftc
justement sur cette les solutions
possibles enfin des solutions
en tout cas sur cette réquisition
possible de l'armée pour transporter les
gens au travail
mais oui j'entends bien que monsieur
barreaux nous nous montre avec
conviction sa volonté de dialogue de
solutions et nous parle d'une commission
le vert qui rendra ses conclusions dans
quelques mois dans six mois
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire pendant ces
six mois alors alors alors ce que je
voudrais dire ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que aujourd'hui il faut débloquer
la situation
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure j'ai l'air
le militaire de france télécom qui
montre toutes les maladresses toutes les
erreurs qui ont été commises les
déclarations en série bande gouvernement
quelle que soit leur bonne volonté
elles s'accumulent elles n'ont pas
d'effet il manque la confiance
aujourd'hui entre le gouvernement et les
français il faut y venir moi je ne vois
pas d'autre solution que de réunir
rapidement les syndicats est en tout cas
ceux qui veulent discuter et à cela on
dit mettons ensemble les bases d'un vrai
dialogue de telle façon que des
décisions rapides soient prises entre
nous et qu'on puisse donner nous indiqua
des assurances au haussariat en grève
aux chômeurs ratp au post it c'est pour
sortir de là on ne peut pas attendre le
dialogue qui n'en finit pas mais dans la
mesure où il n'a pas la confiance entre
les déclarations gouvernementales et les
salariés sortent 11 ans alors qu'ils
vont la discussion avec les groupes des
races
j'ai compris votre question fromage au
dos était bien sympathique ça a servi à
quoi répond à permettre au gouvernement
de choisir les thèmes qu'il a rangé dans
le monde est dans le même temps son
exposition vous et moi aujourd'hui il
faut se dire vraiment on se met les deux
et on diffuse et malheureusement nous
interrompre réponse de monsieur barreaux
on a bien compris votre question moi je
réponds à l'un d'eux le que le
gouvernement est tout à fait ouvert dès
lors que au dialogue dès lors que ce qui
pose des questions les pose vraiment
sans arrière pensée avec le seul souci
d'avoir une information exacte
moi je suis disponible 24 heures sur 24
pour dialoguer et simplement il faut que
on ne nous donne pas et on nous attribue
pas des arrière pensées moi j'ai pas
d'arrière pensée je suis pas là pour
raconter des histoires ce soir je suis
la peau pour expliquer et c'est tout
alors je suis convaincu que tout ce
mouvement de colère et de peur ne
résiste pas quand on donne des bonnes
explications
alors on va le voir on va voir ça tout
de suite au dépôt de la ratp
a aubervilliers est ce que vous seriez
d'accord à cette offre de dialogue de
monsieur barreau qu'est ce que vous en
dites comment est-ce que vous réagissez
et est-ce que éventuellement vous seriez
prêt à suspendre le mouvement pour
reprendre les négociations
chaque fois on tombe dans le piège si on
reprend le travail est bien évident que
adieu adieu adieu d'autres luttes la non
non on n'a pas confiance
monsieur barraute à leur disait que les
français ont peur non non non on n'a pas
peur seulement n'a pas confiance
pas du tout confiance par contre c'est
vrai que moi je suis simple 5 le
machiniste dans un dépôt par contre
expliqué moi monsieur barreaux plus vous
allez le faire travailler plus je vais
prendre la place d'un chauffeur
non expliquez-moi messieurs les
banquiers là si vous voulez être
solidaire avec la france comme vous le
dites
à ce moment là quand on nous oblige nous
fait encore l'état oblige notre
entreprise à construire par exemple le
rer jusqu'à mickey là bas ça nous a
coûté cher parce qu'on a été obligés
d'emprunter chez vous dans les banques
alors au lieu de nous réclamer des
intérêts et bas voulu vous fait cadeau à
la ratp
ça va permettre d'embaucher du monde et
par l'intermédiaire des salaires et par
l'intermédiaire de tout ça on va
peut-être pouvoir redresser une partie
de la del rey sécurité sociale légale
monsieur barça va pas tellement confiant
ça va être très simple un je vais dire à
notre concitoyen machinistes que ce
qu'il dit sur les menaces qui pèsent sur
les retraites est rigoureusement force
il y a simplement le souci de regarder
un peu ce qui va se passer dans l'avenir
ce que font d'ailleurs les syndicats
lorsque comme ils l'ont fait hier il
regarde un petit peu l'avenir du régime
complémentaire qu'ils gèrent eux-mêmes
et regarde un petit peu à 15 et 30 ans
qui va se passer
et moi je regrette mais je dis à notre
concitoyen machinistes faites attention
il s'agit de garantir les retraites de
vos enfants alors au mieux on a si on
avait une décision aujourd'hui qui
révolte la conscience je comprendrais
qu' il soit aussi résolu à en découdre
mais ce n'est pas le cas il y a un
travail de réflexion de concertation qui
est en marche
eh bien laissons le faire et puis on
verra bien et puis pour le reste
bien je lui dirai que nous essayons
justement d'éviter à l'avenir des
déficits qui oblige une partie des
français a toujours accepté des
prélèvements supplémentaires parce que
tout à l'heure j'entendais marc blondel
parler de l'état mais l'état c'est quand
même bien chacun d'entre nous sous la
forme contribuables ou de cotisants
alors il faut bien être raisonnables
l'état s'est pas créé une sorte de mines
d'or qui serait sans fond et où on
puiserait pour boucher les déficits il
faut bien être responsable
non monsieur barreaux monsieur barreau
merci pour votre front va prendre un une
opinion dans notre chez nos invités qui
interviendront la deuxième partie
monsieur bébéar peut-être voulez-vous
réagir à ce que vous avez entendu je
suis un peu étonné si vous voulez que
l'on ne prenne pas en compte les
réalités économiques
j'entends parler du problème des
retraites par exemple le système de
retraite a été mis en place il ya
cinquante ans c'était une époque où il y
avait quatre actifs pour un retraité
c'est à dire qu'il y avait quatre
personnes qui travaillaient pour
financer la retraite d'une personne
aujourd'hui il ya 1,7 actif je crois
pour un retraité
il est évident que le système doit
changer bon j'entends parler aussi de
retrait de la sncf j'ai connu quand
j'étais gosse des gens qui étaient dès
qu'ils conduisaient des machines savez
les machines à vapeur bon à l'époque
prendre la retraite à 50 ans quand on
était comme ça c'était parfaitement
normal aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui conduit
une rame de tgv est installé dans un
système climatisé automatisé et c est ce
que les conditions sont les mêmes
est ce que le même système doit exister
il est évident qu'il faut calmement
examiné choses et faire évoluer sa vie
dans une cei dans une entreprise si
depuis 50 ans n'avait pas évolué eh bien
on serait mort depuis longtemps des
entreprises sont obligés d'évoluer vite
une rue parce que monsieur ben arous
voulez bien sur ce thème là et puis
après nous devrons voir monsieur
monsieur spaihts à la cfdt qui s'agitent
oui je crois simplement que les régimes
de répartition je me suis je veux pas
être trop technique c'est pas mon mon
style mais je suis bien dû s'expliquer
en régime de répartition c'est les
actifs qu'ils cotisent pour les
retraités on est obligé de regarder et
c'est vrai que chaque année nous gagnons
un trimestre de vie les uns et les
autres
ça veut dire qu'il ya un trimestre de
plus de retraites à payer faut voir un
peu comment dans le temps tout ça va
s'organiser
si on refuse et si sous le coup de la
peur on referme le dossier balle dossier
il sera encore plus difficile à régler
en quelques années mais suspecte oui on
vous écoute je voudrais dire plusieurs
choses
tout d'abord je constate que dans
différents secteurs professionnels
il y à des questions très spécifiques il
ya tout d'abord par exemple aux ptt
toute la question de l'ouverture du
capital il faut le traiter la cfdt en
désaccord avec cette orientation
il y à du côté de la sncf la question du
contrat de plan je crois qu'il est
légitime que les salariés s'inquiètent
de leur avenir
s'inquiète de la route y de travail il y
à du côté de sdf les questions de
déréglementation havas je suis opposé
nous sommes opposés au système de
déréglementation alors sur la sécurité
ya sur la sécurité sociale
j'aimerais poser deux questions à
monsieur barreaux tout d'abord il ya ce
qui va pas dans le plan juppé a gelé
déjà dit les retraites on vient
longuement d'en causer ce qui va pas non
plus et la politique familiale notamment
la fiscalisation des prestations
familiales et la report des prestations
autonomie il y a ce qui va dans le bon
sens
il ya la question de la maîtrise des
dépenses de santé et jeffrey aimablement
rome remarquer à monsieur kouchner qu on
connait tous sur le sujet comptant en
fait deux fois plus d'ablation d'appât
dix sites dans un département par
rapport à l'autre on sait ce qui va pas
quand on consomme 30% plus de
médicaments en france que dans les
autres pays européens on sait ce qui va
pas donc il faut maîtriser les dépenses
de santé
et il ya ce qu'il faut concrétiser
rapidement monsieur barreaux voire moins
les choses sont claires je suis pour que
la csg deviennent réelles cotisations et
qu'elle remplace la cotisation maladie
parce que les salariés prennent paye
bien trop de cotisations alors est ce
que vous êtes d'accord sur alors la
dernière question des relations non non
non attendez attendez n'en attendais
parce que si vous posez des questions
toute la soirée après on se souvient
plus de la première alors répondez à
répondre à la question
répondez à la question monsieur barreaux
eh bien d'abord rationnellement
je vais répondre j'aime bien répondre
question par question exactement la
politique familiale
je répondrai que la manière dont on va
en effet
éventuellement mettre les allocations
familiales dans l'assiette est revenu
cette réforme elle va être réalisé dans
un second temps par la loi on en voit
encore en débattre et l'idéal c'est
surtout d'essayer d'aider les familles
qui en ont le plus besoin alors sur le
plan social je crois que il n'y a pas
d'hésitation à dire que nous voulons
faire mieux
deuxièmement deuxièmement je réponds
alors là je suis d'accord
ses pattes nous savons tous que dans
certains cas l'assurance maladie paye
des des frais tout à l'heure j'ai rendu
visite à deux malades du sida
on a parlé c'était c'était tout à fait
dans très simplement et l'un d'eux m'a
expliqué qu'il avait discuté avec le
forfait hospitalier jeu jeudi tous les
choses et en même temps il m'a dit eh
bien je ne prends pas une ambulance
chaque fois pour venir quand je dois
venir un peu me faire regarder et
quelquefois hospitalisé je prends un
taxi ça suffit et j'économise à la
sécurité sociale
il a montré par là qu'il y à un
conditionnement des économies à faire il
l'a dit avec beaucoup de simplicité de
vérité et je n'hésite pas à le reprendre
monsieur ban et troisièmement jeunes
auront à monsieur spaihts mais c'est
effectivement la contribution à venir
eh bien elle sera vraisemblablement
comme l'a dit le produit c'est une
cotisation mais ce barreau visiblement
c'est difficile d'aborder chaque
question individuellement
est ce que avoir un petit peu les
demandes qui sont faites ici et là est
ce qu'il n'est pas question est-ce que
vous envisageriez d'organiser une espèce
de grenelle aujourd'hui une espèce de
grande réunion avec tous les partenaires
sociaux mais s'il s'agit s'expliquer
tout est possible mais ce que je ne
crois pas possible c'est de remettre en
cause le principe de se mettre en marche
pour réformer et sauver notre sécurité
sociale
ça je le dis franchement l'occasion ne
se reproduira pas où nous pourrons en
effet tous ensemble sauver notre
sécurité sociale ou alors nous nous
enfonçons dans les déficits et nous nous
nous nous retrouverons avec des réveils
encore plus douloureux ben là monsieur
baron je voulais vous remercier d'avoir
participé à la première partie de cette
émission vous êtes bien entendu invités
à assister à la seconde en tout cas
merci
d'avoir eu le courage de répondre et la
gentillesse de répondre en direct aux
questions des différents intervenants
dans cette première partie on passe
maintenant à la deuxième partie
nos invités politiques sont invités à
rester avec nous nous inviter syndicaux
également mais je voudrais maintenant
que nous entretenions avec tous ceux qui
nous ont écouté sagement jusqu'à présent
et on va commencer par monsieur enel
monsieur lionel vous êtes parlementaire
rpr sénateur du haut rhin mais c'est pas
à ce titre là que nous avons invité ce
soir monsieur net c'est que vous avez en
grande partie préparer le dossier du
contrat de plan des scènes cf et vous
dites vous vous dites c'est drôle parce
que quand j'en ai discuté mois avec les
syndicats ça avait l'air de passer et
puis au moment d'arriver au moment de la
négociation au nom final fatal
là ça passe plus du contrat de plan tout
cas au moins une partie du contre le
plan ce qui concerne la régionalisation
du transport ferroviaire et non pas de
la sncf
mais j'aurai vous dire tout d'abord que
ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui dans cette
émission c'est l'illustration que plus
personne ne comprend plus personne ne
comprend plus rien et n'a plus confiance
en personne et sait c'est pas pour me
rassurer je crois que j'ai sortir de
cette émission encore plus inquiet que
je n'y suis entré tout à leur fort
justement le délégué de la cftc je crois
disait le problème c'est de la confiance
la confiance elle repose sur quoi repose
sur la vérité d'abord elle repose
ensuite sur la responsabilité des uns et
des autres et le dialogue
aujourd'hui chacun raconte un peu sa
joue sa partition de l'impression qu'on
ne s'écoutent plus au journal non mais
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on s'écoute
plus écoutez moi j'ai eu l'occasion
depuis depuis trois ans que je suis le
dossier sncf
chaque fois que j'avais l'occasion de
rencontrer les organisations
professionnelles
ils sont été jusqu'à me dire il ya plus
qu avec vous qu'on peut discuter
c'est quand même malheureux que les
organisations professionnelles de
cheminots à l'échelon national n'est
plus qu'un parlementaire du fin fond de
la france de l'est c'est quoi votre
affaire extraordinaire que n'aurait pas
le gouvernement qui n'aurait pas
d'autres responsables pardon comment
vous expliquez sur cette difficulté à
dialoguer avec d'autres qu'avec vous
dialoguez c'est d'abord écouter les gens
et puis de voir que ce qu'ils perçoivent
c'est pas forcément ce que ce que nous
nous percevons que la réalité peut être
tout à fait différente
le ressenti qui compte quand on discute
avec des cheminots quand ils vous disent
on comprend pas le on parle même plus
voyez-vous de contrats de plan
maintenant on parle de plan et pour eux
le plan c un plan de restructuration
c'est comme ça qu'ils le ressentent
alors que ça devrait être un plan de
relance du ferroviaire
et si on veut pardon régler le problème
de la sncf faut d'abord qu'on sache
qu'on veut des différents modes de
transport et quand on aura réglé le
problème des voies de transport
on dira quelle est la part de la sncf
pour que la sncf qui était qui a
construit le pays au 19è et au xxème
siècle qui est une grande entreprise
plein de culture de sensibilité mais
aussi parfois d'irrationalité et bien
cette entreprise elle a de l'avenir
c'est le plus bel outil ferroviaire du
monde il en réponse peut-être de
monsieur vaquin sur cette incapacité
peut-être à dialoguer dans l'entreprise
est ce que vous avez un petit peu une
explication là dessus dans la précision
de monsieur vaquin vous êtes non
monsieur vous êtes spécialiste des
problèmes de l'entreprise
ouais je suis surtout spécialiste de
l'analyse des conflits et c'est vrai
qu'il ya je ne suis pas un politologue
moi il ya des choses banales à dire
quand se porte quand même pardon pas
trop quand un banal mais intéressante on
va tenter de faire comme on peut
première question la grève est elle une
agression des usagers par exemple il
faut savoir que si le dialogue social
est en france ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
les acteurs syndicaux ils sont peut-être
un peu pour quelque chose mais pour
dialoguer il faut être plusieurs
or l'état de dialogue social aujourd'hui
fait qu'effectivement les réalités où
sont enterrés depuis fort longtemps ce
qu'il fait que quand il ya conflit ce
qui est un signe de santé dans une
société le conflit c'est toujours un
échec de la parole donc c'est à cet
égard les chefs des tutelles
ministérielles
comme c'est celle des directions des
entreprises quand d'une certaine manière
c'est celle des syndicats peut-être mais
essentiellement les sons les
responsabilités à chacun c'est
impossible de penser aujourd'hui qu'à
pouvoir politique a eu le courage
d'aller jusqu'à encourir le risque de
poser des questions pertinentes et de
les accompagner de telles agressions à
l'égard de l'opinion publique et
particulièrement des salariés de la
fonction publique ont l'euro mais ils ne
savent pas aujourd'hui quel sera le
statut du service public à la française
on ne leur en dit rien des ministres par
les états unis apprennent aux salariés
vous a vu s'exprimer tout à l'heure ce
que seraient des décisions
dont on leur dit par ailleurs elle ne
serait pas prise et peut-être
susceptible d'être négociées j'entends
ce qu'a dit le ministre monsieur fillon
quant à washington il annonce aux gens
des télécoms et aux gens de la poste
qu'ils vont être privatisées à 49 points
à 49% alors quelle crédibilité au
dialogue
il y aura dans 22 méthode monsieur
soubie moins qu'un problème de la
méthode monsieur non attendez si on va
être un tout petit peu sérieux le coude
le coût des échanges à 20 secondes ça ne
marche pas oui non maintenant et dans
les échanges à 3h30 non plus à former
hospitalier en soyons clairs il ya un
vrai fond elle est finie c'est mais je
veux dire ne lisez pas la banaliser
quand on voit l'état du politique tel
que les réponses en soi peu apparues ici
quand on voit la demande tout à fait
légitimes de tous ses salariés qui sont
là à dire j'ai pas confiance et donnez
nous des réponses explicite sur où on va
je rappelle que la fonction du politique
c'est de donner justement ce que serait
une politique ferroviaire pour qu'il
puisse y avoir un contrat de plan c'est
de donner une politique de santé pour
savoir si on gère par les anxiolytiques
ou par le lien social
c'est ça que demandent aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique et les salariés qui
sont en grève alors je voulais qu'on
vient d'arriver avec monsieur soubie
puisqu'il va être dans la commission le
vert et qui va avoir à faire un petit
peu une espèce de sorte de rattrapage de
cours de rattrapage explication alors
oui de rattrapage n'ont pas pas de
rattrapage non ce qui moi me frappe dans
notre débat s'est en effet sa difficulté
je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire sa confusion
mais sa difficulté et je crois c'est
parce qu'il est très difficile et très
confus dans l'esprit des gens et que
pour dériver rites et plus personne n'y
comprend rien y compris ceux qui
s'expriment à son sujet qu'il est normal
qu'il y ait le conflit qui est je crois
une faut pas s'y tromper un conflit très
sérieux et très grave par par ce
phénomène de de traînée de poudre que
nous constatons des quêtes un confit
très sérieux parce que je vais répondre
à votre question
ils portent non seulement sur la
question que vous m'avez posé sur des
régimes de retraite
mais ils posent surtout une série
d'autres questions qui elles ne sont pas
posées qui sont sous jacente et qui
devraient éclater ce qui est des côtes
du rhône c'est plus tellement
quel est le motif du conflit durer
pendant votre question dans le plan
d'alfred alain juppé sur la protection
sociale
il y avait deux sujets il y avait
l'assurance maladie et la santé et puis
il y avait les régimes spéciaux de
retraite sur l'assurance maladie et la
santé je suis totalement d'accord avec
barda kouchner c'est un sujet qui était
préparé depuis
longtemps est au fond la plupart des
experts de tous bords politiques étaient
d'accord et je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans
le conflit que nous connaissons il ya
une très faible part qui vient de la
partie santé assurance maladie du plan
juppé
je crois que l'essentiel du conflit il
vient des retraites
sur le fond le problème est évident en
rien un problème des régimes spéciaux et
d'abord pour les futurs bénéficiaires
c'est évident simplement la mesure est
intervenue alors qu'il n'y avait pas de
réparation jeudi mesure mais il n'y a
pas de mesure parce que la commission qu
alger j'ai l'honneur d'appartenir cela
houlette du président le vert elle part
de quoi elle parle rien je crois que
jacques barrot a dit tout à l'heure que
ce n est rien elle part de risque il ya
une intention du gouvernement sur les
biens que ça ce qui fait qu' un
mouvement qui se déclenche sur quoi sur
une intention est sûre rien ça si c'est
pas un problème de langue à à monsieur
et de communication monsieur d'envoi je
ne sais pas ce que c'est alors pierre
lellouche et monsieur barreau qui nous
écoutent et joyeux de rire louche je
voudrais sur sergent si vous le
permettez je voudrais faire une remarque
qui n'est pas l'âme qui n'est pas la
remarque de quelqu'un qui est engagé en
politique mais du simple citoyen parce
que moi aussi j'ai beaucoup écouté ce
soit
ce qui me frappe dans la situation de
notre débat qui reflète assez bien ce
qui se passe dans le pays
c'est le caractère totalement
irrationnel de ce qu'ils mettent espèce
de mélange une espèce de grand
pot-au-feu où tout est mélangé les
problèmes des étudiants sur tout à fait
réelle l'avenir l'avenir l'avenir des
entreprises publiques
la venue aux entreprises publiques des
postes les df on me sens par les la sncf
les régimes spéciaux qui sont dans
certains cas plus finançables du tout
exemple la sncf 18 milliards de francs
par an payés par le contribuable ses
partenaires faut trouver les solutions
tout ça est mélangé brasser ajouté avec
un peu de djs de désinformation puisque
les gens sont convaincus qu'on va leur
casser leur régime ont valeur convaincu
que les la sncf s'est terminée qu'elle
est privatisée alors que le premier
ministre ne veut pas à privatiser la
sncf ne veut pas priver les privatiser
j'étais là j'ai entendu j'ai entendu
tout à leurs mains de privés de vision
et être permettez je termine je termine
le résultat de tout cela le résultat de
tout cela c'est que les usagers sont
prises en otage l'économie française est
prise en otage les pme vont fermer je
connais des pme qui sont en train de
fermer
et troisièmement nous passons pour des
zozos à l'étranger voilà le résultat de
cette italie relationnel et moi je
trouve
et moi je trouve tout ça écran
réinventant le gouvernement ce sens a
dit négocier la vie à plusieurs débats
je suis ouvert au débat que les façons
d'intéresser les négociations parlement
de faire passer un prochain par
ordonnance ça ce n'est pas le seul
ensuite et comme les instincts sont pas
parce que explique j'explique
mais il faut d'abord écouter or ce qu'il
faut écouter c'est que les projets
actuels ils sont rejetés alors il faut
négocier d'accord il faut discuter
d'accord mais le projet aurait parlé
procédons par or quoi qui va privatiser
la sncf personnes qu'il a privatisé les
postes personne ou le téléphone personne
ce qui va supprimer les régimes sociaux
ce déficit technique
comment ça se fait que je sais quoi
c'est de la désinformation
mais pas c'est curieux saint jean
écoutez alors même si tu as un bel en
deux mots c'est un jean louis outhier
ancien représentant de la cgt métallos
pendant de nombreuses années jusqu'à 88
maintenant vous êtes député européen
très bien ce 4 c'est bien ça moi je suis
quand même surpris d'entendre monsieur
lellouche
à l'entendre il faut faire grève après
mes enfants il faut être raisonnable
monsieur vous êtes complètement à côté
je crois savoir quand même que les
organisations syndicales ont frappé aux
portes de leur direction
aux portes des ministères et lorsque
j'entends le ministre aujourd'hui dire
qu'il veut bien discuter mais qu'il ne
changera rien c'est une véritable
provocation dans cette situation enfin
il faut être raisonnable
vous vous rendez pas compte ce qui se
passe dans le pays moi j'ai quand même
je crois une certaine expérience des
conflits sociaux et j'en ai quand même
traité quelques-uns dans l'industrie
donc je crois savoir de quoi je parle
monsieur et j'avais aussi j'ai été aussi
porteur au nom de mon organisation de
l'avenir industriel de mon pays et j'y
suis encore attaché et il faut bien
écouter ce que posent les gens dans les
conflits qui sont en cours aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus la confiance et c'est là
le problème
il n'y a plus la confiance tout
simplement parce que vous n'avez pas su
prendre les problèmes à la base et vous
n'avez pas su écouter et ça c'est
extrêmement grave pour un gouvernement
qui vient d'être élu et moi je suis
navré de le dire mais je pense
aujourd'hui qu'on est dans une situation
telle qu on risque une généralisation
des conflits pas seulement dans le
secteur public
croyez bien ce que je vous dis pas
seulement en secteur public peut-être
même que certaines industries du privé
vont se mettre dans le coup parce que la
situation est grave et que dans ces
conditions vous n'aurez pas d'autre
choix
négocier saint-jean négocier ou partie
de ces gens je propose une toute petite
réponse de monsieur lellouche
éventuellement là dessus et puis après
un regard qui est intéressant c'est de
voir un petit peu comment l'étranger le
regard de travers et sera souleymane qui
est un professeur de sciences politiques
et que nous rejoindront en duplex des
états unis alors monsieur lellouche
vient c'est un jour moi je vous ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
je crois que vous avez raison sur un
point capital c'est qu'il ya plus ce
climat de confiance entre les
partenaires sociaux et c'est ça qui est
grave et c'est ça qui laissent la place
à toutes les désinformations les
perceptions qui ne sont pas la réalité
donc permettez je termine ma fille si
j'ai permis c'est fini c'est rien
laisser sur monsieur je finissais parce
qu'après on très courageux je souhaite
vraiment de tout coeur que chacun dans
cette affaire et dans les jours qui
viennent dans les heures qui viennent
fassent preuve de responsabilité que
l'on s'assoit autour de la table et
qu'on examine point parfois vous êtes au
pouvoir monsieur le ministre a dit qu'il
était le ministre a dit ton est donné
à toi la disposition des partenaires
sociaux je souhaite qu'on trouve une
réponse très rapidement sur les régimes
spéciaux
une commission va se réunir le plan de
la sécurité sociale va venir au
parlement la semaine prochaine est
entreprise par entreprise il faut que
les gens dit à l'homme si on loge plus
grave que ça c'est l' angoisse qui qui
quitte aujourd'hui se développe en 2010
on a beaucoup d'autres interlocuteurs
je voudrais donner la parole à monsieur
fitoussi mais juste avant parce que la
liaison va s'arrêter je voudrais qu'on
aille à new york
là il ya monsieur les uns sous les mains
monsieur ezra suleiman il est professeur
de sciences politiques et vous êtes peut
être au courant si vous suivez
l'actualité économique
il a parrainé il a chapeauté un grand
article dans time de sexe de cette
semaine sur la possibilité la volonté
des français de débloquer la la société
monsieur souleymane alors vous nous avez
entendu depuis tout à l'heure
à votre avis quelle est la chance de la
france d'arriver à débloquer cette
société qui apparaît bloqué à bien des
égards c'est la société n'est pas
bloquée il y à des blocages maintenant
mais je pense que il faudrait essayer il
faudrait que le gouvernement essaye de
régler est très rapidement ce problème
parce que comme dans tous les conflits
ça dure
nerfs et la situation risque de se
pourrir donc à mon avis il faudrait
essayer de le régler tout de suite
heures oui ça je pense que tout le monde
ça je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord mais la question qui était
posée était peut-être pas assez simple
ou pas assez fermé c'était le sur le
point de savoir quelle est la
possibilité quelles sont les
possibilités de la société française
justement d'aller vers ce type de
solution monsieur vous regardez des
tirailleurs d'abord je vais vous dire
une chose
vous avez posé la question tout à
l'heure de comment les étrangers nous
regardent 1 et bien je pense que d'abord
vu des états unis je parle pas des pays
européens mais vous des états unis on
est à peine conscient on ignore plus ou
mois ce qui se passe à 1 en france à ton
compteur de milliers au gouvernement
calée au 2 milieux financiers à haut
niveau et vous fera via ces messieurs
puisque vous nous observer votre avis à
vous voulez vous observez votre avenir
vous a fait et je pense que il va y
avoir en france à mon avis une règle
structuration très important qui va être
nécessaire et que on a déjà vu aux états
unis on l'a vu en grande bretagne on l'a
vu en allemagne et je pense que la
france est actuellement dans une
situation qui est qui est à la croisée
de chemins si vous voulez et que
il va y avoir beaucoup de
restructurations dont l'emploi il va à
mon avis l'âge d'or et déjà terminée
pour une bonne partie de deux
travailleurs si vous voulez et pour
l'état et donc il va y avoir beaucoup de
sacrifices à mon avis mais pas tout de
suite je bats pas de la situation
actuelle je parle de de nanterre si vous
monsieur souleymane vous écris un livre
qui s'appelle les recettes de la
réussite française
il ya donc des recettes est donc une
réussite aussi quand on compare un petit
peu les pays européens à la france vue
des estives de la passion que la france
est quoi elle est bloquée dans un
certain type d'archaïsme où elle est
capable avec ce contradictions d'évoluer
donc là je pense qu'elle est tout à fait
capable d'évoluer
si je juge parle par son passé et là
était une société complètement si vous
voulez au pratiquement aides débloquées
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale et la
france a été un des pays les plus
dynamiques parmi les pays industriels
donc je pense que personnellement je
suis assez assez optimiste il se trouve
que nous sommes effectivement dans une
situation où la france est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile mais une
situation qu'il a connu par le passé
je pense que par contre sur le moyen
terme et le court terme
je ne suis pas si optimiste je pense à
cause de cette restructuration qu'il va
y avoir à cause du fait que les français
votre être obligé de serrer les
ceintures de céder à des privilèges et
je parle de toutes catégories confondues
que je pense que à court et à moyen
terme il va y avoir beaucoup plus
beaucoup de tension où je prévois bien
monsieur seul mais merci alors un autre
observateur beaucoup moins loin lui les
français c'est monsieur fitoussi
observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques
mais d'entendre ce qu'on a dit depuis
une heure un quart maintenant oui je le
dis à jeûner
j'ai il ya quelque chose qui me frappe
il paraît que vous n'avez rien compris
comme son frère si si si c'est une
question sur laquelle je réfléchis plus
longtemps travers mes raisons donc il ya
quelque chose qui me frappe c'est que ce
conflit concerne en réalité deux points
qui me paraissent importants les études
et la retraite c'est-à-dire les âges
extrêmes de la vie
l'entrée et la sortie dans la vie active
s'il concerne 20 soit aussi important
l'entrée dans la vie active
c'est tout simplement parce que
manifestement notre société a perdu son
avis nous sommes maintenant nous sommes
en défaut dernier et les étudiants ne
perçoivent pas le si vous concerne la
retraite c'est que la retraite c'est
peut-être le dernier repère qui reste
sur l'avenir pour toute une série de
catégories sociales donc cette remarque
ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faille pas
réformer les réactions sont aussi
violente mais bien sûr cette remarque
signifie simplement que nous vivons un
moment où les français sont crispées sur
le présent ils sont en demande d'avenir
et que veut lorsqu'on supprime un
repaire de cet avenir là on risque de
conduire à des conflits de ce type mais
est ce que ça veut dire que dès qu'on
touche à ces points sensibles l'albenc
la france peut pas évolué non au
contraire veut dire que il faut les
toucher tout en donnant un autre avenir
dans la discussion chez les avantages
acquis des avantages qui ne sont pas
illégitimes
ils ont été acquis lorsque l'on supprime
un avantage acquis il faut le remplacer
par un autre avantage on ne réforme pas
une société lorsque on n'a que des
sacrifices à lui demander et aucun
espoir à lui propose pas je crois qu'il
faut indiquer un chemin il faut indiquer
un chemin et il faut que ce chemin s'est
là aussi l'impression que le discours
est trop fait de sacrifices et pas assez
de
venir et de non je crois que il y a eu
deux étapes dans le discours il ya eu le
discours de l'avenir et ensuite le le
discours de deux du sacrifice je crois
qu'il faut mélanger les deux le discours
de l'avenir c'était le discours de
l'actuel président la république
lorsqu'il était en campagne c'était ça
ou vous faites allusion
et je crois que les deux sont liés c'est
à dire le problème c'est que on a cru et
vous les français ont entendu que les
deux étaient scindés alors qu'il
faudrait les relier
comme je crois qu'ils le sont
fondamentalement car en vérité la
réforme des retraites si elle était
nécessaire
le serait pour préserver le régime de
retraite donc pour indiquer un meilleur
avenir
monsieur fitoussi merci avant de passer
la parole à monsieur de revient qui est
encore avec nous est un autre notre
interlocuteur on vient de parler des des
jeunes monsieur galavielle vous avez
gentiment attendue votre votre moment de
parler vous êtes directeur du centre
universitaire pierre mendès-france et ce
qu'on appelle colle bien que oui c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui m'amène est donc alors
sûr sûr sûr sûr sûr les jeux sur les
jeunes sur les jeunes
ce qui me frappe et je rejoins assez
volontiers ce qu'a dit jean paul
fitoussi entre ces deux problèmes de
paul d'état ce qui me frappe c'est que
pour la première fois depuis très
longtemps
nos jeunes manifestent pour quelque
chose et pas contre une circulaire par
contre une loi pas contre un décret ils
manifestent pour avoir les moyens pour
étudier pour pouvoir ne pas être assis
par terre dans les bibliothèques sont
trop plein ils manifestent aussi pour
que lorsque la nation a fait le choix
d'avoir 80 % de ces jeunes au niveau du
bac et c'est un bon choix je le dis eh
bien on leur donne au moins le minimum
de moyens vous avez prononcé tout à leur
insu bilalian le terme de confort
croyez moi moi je vous emmène à pierre
mendès-france je vais vous montrer que
pierre mendès-france n'est
malheureusement pas malgré tous nos
efforts
un lieu de dire j'aime bien devenir
confort j'ai moi même des enfants et
c'est ce qu'il fait ce très court ça
uniquement pour des projets pour des
raisons matérielles ou est-ce qu'ils
manifesteront pas contre ce que leur
propose d'université à la sortie non
c'est pas ça
leurs problèmes en ce moment je vous
dire cela premières affiches qu'ils ont
mises à pierre mendès-france
je note d'ailleurs qui n'ont pas bomber
les murs ils ont fait ça sur du papier
ils ont collé ce papier
parce qu'ils respectent leurs outils de
travail etc noursat aussi un et bien nos
étudiants vous savez ce qu'ils ont écrit
à pierre mendès-france
en gros ils ont écrit étudiants
sacrifier parents licenciés
ça va péter d'accord mais étudiants
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on a des jeunes qui partent de chez
eux où il ya un père une mère au chômage
et parfois les deux qu'ils viennent à la
faculté pour essayer de s'en sortir et
là nous essayons de les accueillir
on n'a pas de locaux il nous manque sim
six ou sept mille mètres carrés à paris
1 nous avons 17 bâtiments dans paris
vous rendez cours de ce que ça
représente
voilà des étudiants qui sont en
désespérance
alors je le dis parce qu'il ya aussi des
jeunes c'est pas par des bagages
williams et arbustes d'un plan parce que
je sais qu'ils ne sont pas de
l'université n'y a plus rien qui nous
écoutent et qui justement des
universités a mis aussi monsieur le
robien
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les jeunes sont effectivement comme ça
en attente énormément de de ce pass
confort matériel justement régis sonnes
ce minimum matériel ils ont à mon avis
vraiment deux préoccupations la première
préoccupation c'est l'état notamment des
locaux l'entretien des locaux qui datent
en général de 1960 et qui sont
insuffisants la plupart du temps et
c'est une vraie revendication
aujourd'hui l'enseignement supérieur n'a
pas assez de moyens matériels et
d'enseignants certainement pour répondre
à la demande
et puis il ya cette espèce d'angoissé
parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui que il y a
deux cent cinquante mille à trois cent
mille jeunes qui sortent de
l'enseignement supérieur chaque année et
il y a environ 60000 cadre postes de
cadres qui sont offerts par les
entreprises et donc il ya un tel hiatus
qu'il ya un sentiment d'inquiétude même
quand on est à mentionner en
enseignement supérieur
alors qu'il ya quelques années on vous
disait bien la fin de trois ans aux
quatre ans ou 5 ans d'enseignement
supérieur vous aurez 10 offre d'emploi
pour un diplôme et donc forcément il ya
une inquiétude et il faut aujourd'hui
réenvisager celle-ci diversion mais je
reviens c'est du constat qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant ce nombre assurer qu'on
fait pour les jeunes et bien pour
l'enseignement supérieur j'estime qu'il
faut d'une part renforcer l'université
et l'enseignement supérieur général 100
sélections
c'est difficile à dire sans sélection me
suis parfaitement avec des
des frais d'entrée les plus minimes
possible pour que le maximum de jeunes
puissent continuer des études qui de
toute façon ne se rend jamais inutile ça
sera de l'enseignement général
ça sera de la formation ça sera une
égalité des chances par davantage
d'enseignements supérieurs
et puis il faut des passerelles avec une
grande branche d'enseignement supérieur
qui soit une branche professionnelle
l'université qu'on dit une filiale
technique ou alors là on peut avec ses
passerelles au bout de deux ans trois
ans ou quatre ans d'enseignement
supérieur général on peut prendre une
filière technique qui vous amène
davantage vers un emploi refuse aussi de
robien oui société revient à voter die
ramaré à tort monsieur monsieur monsieur
galavielle et madame quand vous oubliez
répondre à l'université a fait des
efforts considérables en collaboration
avec le milieu des entreprises parce que
la vieille lune de l'université qu'il
veut pas vivre à contre-pied c'est fini
depuis 20 ans à un les universités ont
fait de gros effort de ce côté là nous
avons créé des diplômes en collaboration
avec les entreprises pour des filières
professionnalisées eh bien je vais vous
dire ce qui se produit aujourd'hui c'est
que lorsqu'on a des drs s
où on doit avoir des professionnels qui
font des cours et des ss et nous nous y
accueillons bien volontiers mais
lorsqu'une et aussi il faut qu'ils
fassent des stages ça fait partie de la
loire et et bien ces entreprises qui il
y a quelques années
prenez des stagiaires les paient au bout
de quatre ou cinq ans elles ont arrêté
les payer et maintenant elle ne les
prenne plus alors vous comprenez la
désespérance aussi bien vous êtes
d'accord pour accepter tout le monde
anniversaire façon pas de sélection ce
que vous dites aussi vous absolument
on ne peut pas construire les lignes sur
une ce sujet
attendez je vous donne un parlement à
nommer monsieur barreau va nous quitter
parce qu'il a des obligations je
voudrais le remercier d'abord et
je suppose qu'il parle d'humiliation oui
plusieurs en cette fin de semaine des
négociations
monsieur ben je voulais vous remercier
d'abord d'avoir participé à notre débat
avec beaucoup de franchise simplement
peut-être vouliez-vous dire un mot avant
de nous quitter oui je voudrais faire un
peu écho à ce qu'a dit jean paul
fitoussi
au fond pourquoi ça va pas bien ce soir
parce qu'il ya un déficit d'espérance il
un déficit d'espoir mais c'est difficile
d'espoir et vaut bien le reconnaître
c'est le prix que nous payons pour
n'avoir pas su faire les adaptations en
temps voulu quand on retarde un peu
l'adaptation est bien
l'espoir vient plus tard c'est pour ça
que le ministre du travail que je suis
je suis avant tout mieux au travail ce
que je fais en essayant de avec sochaux
ii dans le cadre du gouvernement c'est
d'essayer de mettre un peu d'ordre pour
que nous soyons plus fort et moi je suis
convaincu que cette période d'adaptation
est douloureuse mais si on se serre les
coudes
les français peuvent être capable d'être
les meilleurs mais un effet nous ne
combleront pas ce déficit d'espérance il
ne nous mettons pas en chemin mais c'est
marrant merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir madame borvo tout d'abord
qui voyagent ils voulaient réagir à ce
que dit monsieur barreaux et il dit un
manque d'espérance mais je crois que ce
qu'il ya c'est une
un divorce et un profond profond entre
les politiques qui sont menées
maintenant depuis des années les gens en
ont assez et la population et ça il faut
bien le prendre en compte qu'il faut que
vous le preniez en compte parce que vous
dites on est prêts au débat mais à
partir de ça les étudiants qu'est ce
qu'ils demandent chantant monsieur de
rebière qu'il dit il faut il faut il
former les étudiants ils demandent qu'on
réponde à leurs aspirations légitimes à
faire des études parce que ça les études
c'est l'avenir de notre pays et vous ré
le minime monsieur bayrou répond par des
petites des 200 millions alors qu'on
sait très bien de 100 millions c'est
rien du tout le nombre de postes qu'ils
proposent c'est ce qui correspond à la
demande d'une scène universitaire vous
n'avez pas l'air d'accord non plus tout
à l'heure non monsieur parrot est parti
alors je le dis quand même bien sûr
déficit d'espérance bien sûr grande
angoisse mais quand même il y a eu un
gouvernement qui avant le juppé 1 était
celui de que vous savez puis il ya une
campagne électorale
alors si on comprend pas c'est qui a eu
tant de promesses faites sans doute pour
l'élection mais si on n'aime plus les
politiques c'est aussi parce qu'ils font
des promesses qui ne correspondent pas à
la réalité et on disait à chacune de ces
catégories qui nous intéresse ce soir y
compris les cheminots les retraités les
étudiants et on a dit des choses sur
l'assurance maladie
et puis on a fait exactement le
contraire et les gens n'ont plus rien
compris ce qui accentue l angoisse alors
sur l' angoisse faut pas simplement dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait faut pas simplement
découvrir le symptôme faut connaître les
raisons de langouët ce qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent ces français en effet est-ce
qu'ils vont aller plus loin parce qu on
leur répond pas on ne répond pas encore
ce soir et je crains personne continue
c'est un troll angoisses des jeunes
autant cessé d'aller retrouver à
toulouse on va retourner tout de suite à
l'hiver c'est toulouse qui voulait ça
fait un moment qu'on les a pas entendus
et je crois que sur l' angoisse puisque
vous êtes angoissé paraît-il d'après en
tout cas l'avis de nos invités
qu'est ce que vous dites là dessus déjà
je voudrais faire une remarque
comme ça en général c'est que pour une
émission qui s'appelle la france en
direct
je pense qu'elle a laissé très peu la
parole aux premiers concernés qui
étaient les salariés les étudiants déjà
une première remarque et en plus je
voudrais simplement souligné qu' on a
des choses à proposer nous je me
satisfais pas de poser des questions
monsieur barroso lui non mais justement
justement continuer parce que nos
revendications sont passés je voudrais
simplement précisé que le dialogue s'est
pas uniquement question réponse avec un
gouvernement qui serait et des étudiants
ou des salariés qui ne saurait passer
aisément se bat on veut des enfants
on se bat pour des réformes en positif
on a une idée de ce qu'on veut de
l'université qu'on veut c'est
effectivement une université publique
qui donne une égalité devant l'éducation
pour tous et qui nous donne une
possibilité d'avoir un emploi avec une
formation générale qui soit la plus
solide possible et non sans un peu par
essence non seulement budget selon idc
les problèmes aussi de structures de
l'université de vocation de l'université
et au cours de l'un de nos forums en
demander quelle place de l'université au
sein de la société
à une époque où un diplôme diffusé gala
un emploi alors c'est une réflexion qui
bien plus profonde
moi j'invite ses fans vas-y a pas parlé
un peu plus parce que vous nous censurer
sans arrêt en tout cas on peut pas
parler
stéphane ont essuyé pas des noms ployer
pas des grands mots puisque on vous a
invité on a partagé en bossant sur f ou
simplement change il doit prendre
s'il vous plaît mais dès qu'il est
question de censure et personnes
attention au faux pas employer les mots
comme ça si on vous invite ses parures
vous censurez seulement tout le monde ne
peut pas parler autant qu'il le veut
bien entendu parce qu'il faut laisser
tout le monde s'est exprimé
et ça n'est pas facile parce que
visiblement il ya des problèmes de
communication ne sont pas tellement de
renouer vous mais entre on l'a compris
le gouvernement les politiques et que
c'était les responsables faites
attention aux termes que vous employez
alors dites nous où nous allons et nous
dire ce soir de considérer ce rectangle
de considérer que nous avons des choses
positives apportées et que ça se soit
entendu
il ya une réforme de l'université qui se
décident en haut lieu et je crois qu'on
a des choses à dire là dessus c'est ce
que je vous expliquais c'est par rapport
à l'emploi c'est par rapport à des
questions de fond que nous disons est
que nous répondrons dit nous allons
aborder les baptiser ses comptes avant
de lui parler de la question des
étudiants aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
statut social étudiant nous sommes une
population qui est complètement social
de l'étudiant doit absolument non mais
c'est vrai nous sommes indépendants de
fait puisque nous vivons en général à
l'extérieur de notre famille nous avons
une vie propre
mais nous n'avons pas de revenu saas est
une question qui se pose qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des étudiants comment on les
considère dans la société
je pense que la société a un devoir
d'éducation envers eux et que ça vous
permettez qu'on y répondre vous
permettez qu'on essaye d'y régler sa
situation à dubaï et doit répondre à
votre question peut même pas dire you
est une affirmation
ah bon d'accord abbas assez différent si
vous faites les questions et les régions
nous donnent la parole je pense qu'il
faut qu'on en profite toujours du bon
d'accord vous ne posez pas de questions
vous prenez la part voilà on va quand
même essayer de répondre le statut
social de oui et il ya quelques petits
constate qu'ici on va faire dans des
délais brefs donc je vais vous donner
des chiffres parce que je crains que du
côté du politique comme de l'ensemble de
l'opinion
il ya des choses qui soient très
évidente et qu'on ne prend pas assez en
compte entre autres qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une raréfaction de l'emploi qui crée le
phénomène de panique
tant parmi les licences yable que parmi
les salariés à statut
je vais vous donner de chiffres nous
avons 16 millions de salariés licenciés
à blanc france qui possiblement pourrait
travailler
parmi ceux là il ya 5 millions d'acteurs
qui sont hors travail il ya cinq
millions de salariés qui sont dits d
atypique
c'est à dire des gens qui sont pas en
contrat à durée indéterminée deux jours
ils sont soignés vous 5 millions cela
c'est des gens qui sont un temps partiel
en stage en intérim
ça fait sur 16 millions des millions
d'acteurs qui ne sont pas dans la norme
eh bien ça monsieur ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il contient une majorité
d'acteurs qui ne sont pas dans la norme
c'est que la norme délire et la norme
qui délire aujourd'hui c'est la suivante
ça fait 20 ans qu'on a déclaré gauche
droite confondues tous les syndicats la
guerre allant au chômage
on a perdu des batailles jusqu'à avoir
aujourd'hui les 5 millions d'acteurs
dont je parle c'est ça qui derrière tout
est ce qui est commun à tous les
mécontentements qui ont ici présents
avec la prise en compte de cette
raréfaction de l'emploi qu'il est fait
par personne on est toujours dans la
lecture du plein emploi et tant qu'on
est dans une situation de cet ordre il
n'y a pas d'issue que par la
déflagration telle qu'elle peut se
produire si ses problèmes de santé qui
secoue bien avec de l'arrêt de travail
on peut être aller à strasbourg à la
pause l'ol peut là aussi puisque les
apatrides petit moment ce qu'ils ont à
dire avant de parler à plat il a passé
la parole à monsieur lellouche très vite
passant par le centre de la poste
strasbourg
monsieur donc à strasbourg nous sommes
contents de devoir de pouvoir prendre la
parole en fin
on a plein de choses à dire les coupes
les politiques ont confisqué toute la
soirée la parole quoi est bon ils ont
dix longues et des choses qu'on connaît
qu'on qui nous a rabâché depuis des
années les seules choses sérieuses ont
été dites par monsieur bacau mais ce
fitoussi avec des mots savants certes
mais qui repré c'est-à-dire qui
retransmettent un peu qui retransmettent
nos pensées alors qu'est ce que vous
avez envie de dire ce soir nous
angoisser nous attendre donc nous on bon
moi je veux qu'on l'a on ya centre de
tri en grève depuis deux jours
1 donc on ne fait pas la grève par on ne
fait pas la grève par par plaisir quoi
donc comment je veux dire bonsu sipan
habitués de la parole du coin donc je
bégayais un peu mais bon on est là on
nous traite de nantis on nous traite de
privilégié qu'est ce que c'est nous on
travaille on travaille 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7
nous avons sur 600 employés nous avons
100 heures de sens en type de prise de
bach à sion différentes ou d'horaires
différents quoi 11 on a des jeunes qui
viennent de trois heures du matin 6
heures du matin nous avons des crs nous
avons des cdd nous avons des cdi nous
avons des prêts qu il n'y a qu' il n'y a
que des il n'y a que des précaires c'est
ça l'avenir de nos enfants nous c'est ce
que ses amis nous sommes des
consommateurs nous sommes des nous
sommes des travailleurs aussi quoi donc
toutes les angoisses c'est à dire on a
on est on a plein plein d'angoissé quoi
qu'on n'arrive pas qu'on n'arrive pas à
l'exprimer
à ax pris avec les ce sont des angoisses
vous avez par rapport à l'avenir et par
rapport à vos enfants et pas tellement
par rapport à votre travail à vous mais
si parlera pas par rapport à ne
travaille évidemment évidemment par
rapport à notre travail aussi bon je
vais pas revenir je vais pas revenir bon
sur tout ce qui a été dit ce soir donc
la poste et quoi c'est on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas ce qu'on va devenir un donc
notre statut bon je ne parle plus des
retraites dépenser un malaise très très
générale ya eu la réforme de la il ya eu
la réforme de la de la poste en 1990 on
nous a promis on nous a promis à ces
messieurs
on se retrouve ici avec des salaires
yeux et salaires de misère avec thé avec
plus de plus de perspectives de carrière
avec monsieur bon avenir complètement
complètement bouché monsieur je vous
interromps comprendre exactement ce que
vous ressentez vous dit vous avez fait
allusion à monsieur fitoussi tout avoir
voulu dire que vous êtes vous êtes comme
il l'a expliqué quelqu'un qui n'a pas le
sentiment qu'il va pouvoir avoir une
retraite paisible c'était ça me convient
et la retraite certainement joué là
j'aurai la retraite
bon moi je me défends c'est évidemment
fait un peu d'auto défense mais on pense
surtout à nos enfants aux générations on
pense surtout aux générations à venir
1 donc non ça sortait non ça sortira
toujours on s'en sortira toujours mais
n'est pas si vrai que commandé il ya des
jeunes que vont devenir les jeunes
comment est ce que vous ressentez le
fait que quelquefois éventuellement dans
les manifestations sur le terrain des
gens puissent vous dire mais vous quand
même dans la fonction publique dans
l'espace public vous êtes privilégié
parce que vous êtes quand même protégé
est-ce quelque chose que vous que vous
fait réagir ça moi je ne me sens pas
privilégié je travaille de nuit je
travail de 7 heures du soir jusqu'à 6h
du matin je travaille
bon c'est décidé vacations qui sont
longues et pénibles bon ok j'ai la
possibilité de partir à 55 ans si j'ai
37 ans et demi de retraite
si j'ai 37 ans et demi de travail 1 donc
où je me demande où je suis privilégié
je gagne 8500 balle par mois j'ai 24 ans
jay 24 ans 2 2
2 d'ancienneté quoi je ne vois pas du
tout ce que je on va essayer de répondre
à ce que vous venez d exprimer
pierre lellouche là on a une expression
et je poserai la question à monsieur
saint jouin pour l'art et l'expression
j'allais dire de la dame qui nous livre
son coeur l'a alors tort raison c'est un
autre problème là il vous dit ce qu'il
pense il est absolument pas tort cet
homme là n'a pas tort ceux qui sont en
grève n'ont pas tort je le dis moi je
suis dans la majorité et je suis député
de la majorité
je comprends parfaitement l'angoissent
qui amène des gens à se mettre en grève
je comprends l'angoissé des jeunes
devant un marché du travail qui c'est
sans espoir souvent dans des conditions
telles inégalités travail qui se mettent
en grève je comprends les entreprises
publiques
ils savent que le monde est en train de
changer qui sont menacés nous faisons
moins d'enfants donc nous savons que
notre régime de retraite ne sera plus le
même
moi même j'ai une assurance privée parce
que je sais que la retraite que j'ai eue
avant à l'université ne suffira pas
alors tout le monde vit cette angoisse
le drame aujourd'hui là je veux je veux
dans le lit et comprend mais qd âge
qu'on peut résumer en quoi cela mettez
moi j'y arrive
monsieur
je vous ai pas interrompues a défini les
spécialistes du conflit et vous et je
vous ai pas adhérentes
oui à quel point ce que je voulais dire
c'est ce que je voulais dire ces choses
suivantes
aujourd'hui la france est en train de
payer beaucoup beaucoup d'années de
réforme pas fait
nous sommes le dernier pays en europe
par exemple avoir transformé et vous
préparer à la compétition nous
entreprises publiques
nous sommes en train de mener en ce
moment à bruxelles une bataille
d'arrière garde pour éviter justement la
privatisation sauvage de france télécom
ou d'edf gdf
contrairement à ce que croient les
grévistes ces réformes n'ont pas été
faits nous trouvons une situation
financière
fitoussi disais justement il ya les
jeunes à côté les retraités de l'autre
tout le monde tout le monde en fait les
consommateurs d'argent public il ya plus
d'argent public il ya une dette publique
de 3500 milliards de francs ya
remboursement annuel qu'on donne aux
banquiers madame on donne deuxième
budget de l'état 240 milliards qui va
directement aux banques et tous les ans
donc ça ne peut plus durer
plutôt qu'un problème à nous monsieur
l'expert des conflits c'est quoi c'est
d'essayer de remettre de l'ordre dans
ses finances est très désagréable de
sauver la sécurité sociale de sauver nos
entreprises publiques
moi je suis aussi attachée que vous
allez cncr parce que je connais
l'histoire la troisième république et je
sais que derrière en plus si hajek
alstom ya le tgv il ya tous les excès
des exportations de qu'il est vital de
sauver ces boîtes mais on ne peut pas
sauver ces boîtes en se mettant
paralysant le pays et en disant il n'y a
pas de solution nous ne sommes pas
diriger donc on se met en grève donc on
me ménage peut le consommer yeux vous
dis non je dis je comprends mais je fais
appel maintenant permettez je termine
d'après je dirais plus je fais
simplement appel parce qu'on a la
responsabilité de chacun dans cette
affaire nous devons nous comporter en
citoyens responsables chacun à notre
place que ce soit les dirigeants des
syndicats ou les dirigeants
d'entreprises que ce soit les hommes
politiques les parlementaires le
gouvernement justement notre avenir est
en jeu car était un dernier mot si nous
ne faisons pas aujourd'hui ses réformes
si par malheur si par malheur
l'irrationnel devait l'emporter et que
devant les échéances incontournable de
ce pays
il ne se passe rien alors ces
entreprises là c'est foutu la sécurité
sociale aussi et on en attendre encore
30 ans attendait avant de retourner sur
le terrain simple
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait 2010
j'aimerais bien qu'on est juste eu un
petit bout de monsieur bb1 parce que sur
cette angoisse qui est exprimée ici sur
le terrain partout les gens qui font
grève parce que vous dans des
entreprises privées est ce que vous avez
ce genre de manifestation aussi des
salariés
c'est évident que les gens sont
angoissés parce que ils se demandent les
jeunes en particulier ceux de vente il
va y avoir un emploi pour eux le jour
des réponses au monsieur là quelques que
je vois le postier il dit moi mon
problème je me débrouillerai
effectivement en plus il a un statut qui
les protège
il est angoissé pour ses enfants il n'a
pas tort d'être envoyés pour ses enfants
mais pour si on veut résoudre le
problème du travail des jeunes
il faut absolument être capable de créer
des emplois il faut donc sonné une
machine économique qui tourne alors ce
que je voudrais pour dans l'immédiat des
angoisses assure que je propose
justement pour les jeunes c'est qu'on
développe vigoureusement ce qu'on
appelle la formation duale
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure on a
parlé tout à l'heure de la delà de la
conjonction fait delà de l'action
concertée des entreprises et
l'université mais il faut faire repartir
ça il faut que nous les entreprises nous
soyons capables d'offrir à nos jeunes la
formation duale
c'est à dire que nous prenions ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire quoi concrètement
ça veut dire qu'il faut que dans nos
effectifs nous soyons capables de
prendre en formation duale salle
d'accueil des étudiants qui sont
étudiants de répondre en même temps on
travaille dans l'eau entre ça ce sont
les étudiants ça c'est pour les jeunes
en formation dans ce dossier qui vous
interpellent de ce que vous dites et
pour se poster qui m'interpelle je lui
dis monsieur vous avez votre régime qui
vous permet de vous êtes protégé
vous ne m'avez pas d'inquiétude pour
votre emploi premier élément
deuxièmement sur le problème de votre
retraite oui il est certain que vous
n'aurez pas à terme la retraite qu'on eu
vos parents par exemple corps lettres
actuelle vos parents pourquoi parce que
nous n'avons pas assez de jeunes faut
bien voir que c'est que la rue la la
retraite ce sont les actifs qu'ils
paient pour leurs parents et pour leurs
grands parents
comme nous avons moins de jeunes comme
nous avons plus de personnes âgées
nous n'aurons pas assez de jeunes pour
payer nos retraites donc il faut pas se
faire d'illusions en retraite ne seront
pas au niveau
de celles que nous servons aujourd'hui
allo parents et grands-parents mes
sensations et je l'accepté sans sinon
sinon on est toutes les réponses
monsieur moi c'est pas tellement ma
retraite qui me préoccupe je ne pense
pas je ne pense pas parce
qu'individuellement on arrivera
peut-être nous à une tranche d'âge entre
40 et 50 ans on arriverait tout ça s'en
sortir ou plus ou moins eu moins en
étant fonctionnaire a bondi en écho on a
la garantie de l'emploi en a plein de
choses des bombes
il n'y a pas que nous dans le jeu et
c'est à dire nous on a eu un niveau
d'emploi qui était correct et qu'on va
laisser coi derrière nous on va laisser
des cimetières d'emploi des idées des
oueds touba et tout et tout est
sinistrée où tout va être sinistre et on
n'a pas le droit de faire ça c'est à
dire on n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le
droit de laisser faire j'aurais juste
ajouté oui s'il ya effectivement un
problème de proportions par les actifs
et les retraités c'est bien à cause des
suppressions d'emplois et qu il suffire
des actifs et les retraités c'est bien à
cause des suppressions d'emplois et
qu'il suffirait effectivement d'avoir
une politique en faveur de l'emploi pour
renverser la vapeur et pu rééquilibrer
la protection sociale à la jeu messieurs
je vous remercie vous reste maintenant
que chacun puisse une dernière fois
s'est exprimé tout le monde n'a pas pu
s'exprimer aussi longuement qu'il ne
souhaitait mais ça c'est un petit peu la
règle du jeu
on va repartir déjà pour que chacun
puisse nous dire ce qui conclut de ce
débat que nous avons eu ce soir qui loin
d'être parfait mais il a au moins le
mérite d'exister et c'est déjà important
alors on va repartir du côté de nos amis
syndicalistes d'abord monsieur blondel
ou nous avait écoutés après avoir et 13
être intervenu souvent dans la première
partie
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la fin de
ce débat sur la manière d'appréhender
l'ensemble de ces problèmes
si vous me permettez l'observation les
jeunes sont 8 millions entre 15 et 24
ans ça veut dire 8 millions de jeunes
qui auront entre 20 et 30 ans en l'an
2000 quand on discute avec eux il y en a
pas qui est sûr d'avoir un emploi
voilà l'angoissent voilà le fond et on
retrouve ça au schiste et les salariés
et ce soir je m'étonne qu'on n'ait pas
mis à profit justement et je pensais que
c'était le piège pour les syndicalistes
à profit votre émission pour essayer
d'avoir une
sur un dialogue une proposition moi je
veux dire j'ai entendu monsieur barreau
dire qu'ils avaient peur ou plus
exactement qu'il fallait que nous
dépassions nos peurs mais c'est lui qui
a peur il a peur que le mouvement
s'amplifie et il va s'amplifier lundi ça
sera mieux qu'aujourd'hui dans le
domaine de l'agraire justement mais moi
je ne le fip fait pas et je n'en tire
pas fierté je dis simplement on ne nous
répond pas parce qu'on ne veut pas
dialoguer alors monsieur méprise les
organisations syndicales suite solution
dernier à l'étape suis moi de le dire
la représentation parlementaire est ce
qui a fait sauter le vase ce qui avait
mis reborn est drôle le système est bien
c'est sur la sécurité sociale parce que
ça reste quand même le minimum qu
illusion de monsieur blondel sa saisine
effectivement les gens nous suivent dans
la merci beaucoup monsieur blondel nous
avons réseau parce qu'ils espèrent eux
merci beaucoup merci on va retourner si
vous voulez bien tout de suite au mans à
la sncf pour un petit peu le ciment ce
qui va se passer dans les jours qui
viennent
bonsoir messieurs alors on a beaucoup
parlé d' angoisse on a beaucoup parlé de
l'avenir dans cette fin d'émission
l'avenir immédiat c'est quoi pour vous
demain c'est pas à l'avenir immédiat je
sais pas mais tout ce qu'on peut dire je
voudrais seulement précisé que la
moyenne de vie d'un agent de conduite
est de 57 ans et si on écoute ce qui est
écrit ou plutôt si on applique ce qui
est dans le contrat de plan et bien je
suis même pas sûr moi de pouvoir partir
en retraite et j'aurais bien aimé que ce
soir ici ou plutôt y compris à
strasbourg les gars de la ratp tous les
travailleurs en lutte dans ce pays
puis c'est un peu plus avoir la parole
et pas seulement dans les salons
parisiens ou là vraiment ça a été assez
scandaleux y est on prêt on peut
comprendre que les salariés
elle a bien fallu pour vous voyez là où
vous faites grêve c'est à dire sur ce
dégoût du maure l'occurrence messieurs
je le remercie je vous assure qu'on
n'est pas près d'être bandeau question
d'ajouter si on a de la question
laquelle vous avez l'oreille je voulais
simplement insister sur le fait que
contrairement à ce qu'a pu dire monsieur
barreaux tout à l'heure les cheminots en
particulier n'ont pas peur du changement
notre mouvement actuellement c'est ça
dépasse les problèmes de sécurité
sociale ou de retraites c'est vraiment
tout là toute la défense du service
public
pour ce qui nous concerne c'est en
particulier au travers de ce contrat de
plan le contrat de plan mis en place
concrètement c'est des fermetures de
ligne c'est 6000 km de lignes qui risque
d'être fermé ses 6000 emplois par an
pendant cinq ans donc trente mille
emplois qui risquent d'être supprimés et
très concrètement j'avais une question à
poser à monsieur enel ou aux députés oui
père monsieur lellouche wii ou à
monsieur barreau malheureusement il est
parti
oui
ligne là sur la sarthe attendait une
ligne qui fait qui dessert ou caen
alençon le mans tours il est fortement
question qu'au travers de ce contrat de
plan elles soient fermés bien j'aurais
aimé avoir des certitudes par rapport à
l'avenir de cette ligne mais ça c'est du
service public et c'est pourquoi nous
sommes en grève actuellement mais cela
de problème mais comment dire
comment dire particulier d'accord ce
n'est d'accord encore que là il s'agit
d'un exemple tout à fait particulier
quand même salle cela dit simplement
avant de continuer avec le représentant
de la secte et je voudrais vous dire que
c'est pas un salon parisien ici te mais
monsieur c'est un studio et nous sommes
des journalistes et nous ne sommes pas
dans un salon quand même pas exagérer
les choses
monsieur je fais cela deux de la cfdt
oui je suis dans une organisation
syndicale qui 32 prendre en compte
l'intérêt général et pour moi l'intérêt
général c'est une sécurité sociale
c'était un grand sujet financer d'une
manière juste et ouvert à tous et sur la
question des retraites qui a été
longuement abordée c'est
incontestablement aussi une question
d'emploi et je crois que pour les jeunes
c'est bien sûr une formation de qualité
ça demande des moyens mais c'est aussi
des débouchés et je souhaite je pousse
on agit à la cfdt pour que les
entreprises ouvrent la porte aux jeunes
face de la place et donc nous poussons
partout pour la réduction du temps de
travail comme nous l'avons fait par
exemple en matière de retraite départ la
retraite rap et 40 ans de travail avec
un d'accord quel que soit l'âge et
remplacement par un jeune
voilà une action positive qu'il faut
généraliser et je crois que c'est et
c'est mon rêve et j'arrêterai là dessus
ce qu'on arrive à avoir des cessation
progressive d'activité notamment pour
ceux qui ont des carrières longues et
difficiles je pense à tous les postés
aux gens qui font le travail de nuit
dans toutes les professions privé au
public et que l'on fasse d entrée
progressive dans la vie active pour tous
les jeunes qui ne demandent que ça qu'on
a réussi à recoller monsieur noir c'est
merci monsieur spec donc on va retourner
maintenant à la ratp
aubervilliers ses chevilles amer sur le
dépôt de berrier quand on parle
d'évolution est ce que vous seriez par
exemple près vous à la ratp à voir
évoluer votre statut mais moi je vais
vous répondre
un petit peu à côté de votre question à
la soupe de messieurs barreaux lellouche
on la connaît on la refuse
on la refusera jusqu'au bout que je peux
dire aussi c'est qu'on appelle les gars
du privé tous les copains des services
publics les étudiants l'ensemble des
français à descendre dans la rue
ma défense oui on nous doit et là dessus
je peux dire qu on est déterminés on ira
jouer simplement vous demander si une
france en direct
puisqu'on puisqu'on dit que puisqu'on
dit quelquefois que vous êtes agrippé
figé on est bloqué sur un statut
particulier ou sur des avantages acquis
est ce que c'est une idée fausse ou
escaut qu'on fait est qu'au contraire
vous êtes tout à fait prêt à envisager
des modifications dans votre statut pour
votre avenir
eh bien je vais vous répondre en corps à
corps est encore attendue en variante
extrême ne répondait on est voté on a
compris que pour les invités de frissons
dans le rapport de la députée monsieur
ne peut pas continuer à pouvoir les voir
monsieur duteil de la cgt bon vous avez
vous avez fait ce que vous vouliez dire
monsieur duteil enfin ça fait leur je
demande la parole et moi je comprends
les grévistes qui sont pas content ce
soir
moi je mets à leur place ce barreau
noyer le poisson
qu'est ce qu'il aurait pu dire et du
dire ce soir je retire le plan juppé art
sncf et edf à la poste à france télécom
je retire les mauvais projet de
déréglementation et je crois qu'à une
conclusion qui découle de cette soirée
c'est le gouvernement persiste c'est pas
un problème de méthode il veut pas
s'attaquer à l'argent monsieur b br ne
proteste pas les profits de l'entreprise
sont fabuleux les jeunes ont eu leur
donner l'argent pour une diversité on
préfère le mettre dans les bombes
nucléaires ou dans les essais en la
question qui est posée c'est les
salariés qui vont décider se rassembler
s'unir pour suivre l'action et en ce qui
nous concerne la cgt nous serons à leurs
côtés et je dis ce soir
pourquoi pas dès le début de la semaine
prochaine examinez la poursuite de
l'action et l'examiner dans tous les
services publics et avec le privé
également et en ce qui nous concerne à
la cgt nous prendrons nos
responsabilités
merci donc on continue le tour le
dernier son syndicat avec monsieur de le
à la cftc
monsieur de le oui moi dans ce qui ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure j'étais
d'abord frappé par cet appel des jeunes
à avoir leur place dans la société et à
être écoutés et entendus
je croyais en temps de mes enfants et ça
nous adultes nous devons l'entendre
vraiment la priorité c'est les jeunes et
quand j'entendais monsieur fitoussi nous
dire la france est en défaut d'avenir
c'est un des points qui a été négligée
jusqu'à présent dans le débat de la
réforme de monsieur juppé c'est la
politique familiale est ce que vous
savez qu'en france en moyenne une
famille à un enfant de moins qu'elle ne
l'aurait souhaité un de moins
dans chaque famille en moyenne il manque
un enfant qui n'est pas là qu'on aurait
voulu
et qu'est ce qu'on nous propose en face
de ça on nous propose le gel des
prestations et on nous propose un impôt
sur
enfants c'est inadmissible alors
monsieur barreau nous a dit un grenelle
pour la sécu pourquoi pas il faut
réformer la sécu nous sommes d'accord
réformons la réforme on l'a ensemble
dans un grenelle de la sécu mais moi je
dis une chose aujourd'hui non pas dans
six mois
aujourd'hui dans un train quand un
passager tire le signal d'alarmé
est ce que le conducteur du train peut
continuer comme si de rien n'était moi
je vous pose la question bien mais si on
restera sur cette interrogation pour ce
qui vous concerne peut-être de manière
un tout petit peu plus rapide et
synthétique monsieur de robien qui avait
suivi ce débat qui avait participé
également
oui j'ai écouté attentivement ce débat
de ma province et pas dans un salon il
dans un studio parisien peu importe donc
avec un petit peu de recul et j'ai
l'impression que la france en direct
c'est une france qui ne s'est pas
s'écouter qui n'a pas encore trouvé
alors qu'on donne des leçons de
démocratie un peu partout qui n'a pas
encore trouvé suffisamment de d'éléments
démocratie pour savoir dialoguer écouter
les points de vue de l'autre et
peut-être pour être très court puisque
on est tous d'accord sur le constat que
c'est la jeunesse finalement qui doit
être prioritaire est bien est ce que les
adultes ne pourrait pas donner un petit
peu l'exemple d'adultes responsables qui
ne doivent pas ajouter à l'angoissé des
jeunes et donc soyons tous un peu
responsables la place où nous sommes
les responsables politiques ou les
responsables syndicaux et arrêtons de
jouer un jeu de d'opposant systématique
pour essayer de faire du positif et ne
pas insister match systématiquement
cherché l'affrontement mais seront bien
merci donc on va puisque on arrive à la
fin de cette émission retourner voir la
jeunesse c'est à dire la faculté à
toulouse ou pour une conclusion donc là
j'aimerais bien que vous nous disiez ce
que vous avez à nous dire de façon assez
synthétique est assez rapide si vous
voulez bien éventuellement ce que vous
avez retenu
au débat et nous les représentants
politiques que ce soir les représentants
du gouvernement ont parlé à plusieurs
à plusieurs moments de réenvisager
universités ensemble de trouver du
travail ensemble de nous aider à faire
des études de nous aider à préparer
notre avenir et dernièrement monsieur de
robien viennent de nous dire que pour
lui la jeunesse était prioritaire je
voudrais lui rappeler que cela fait
trois semaines que dans certaines
facultés les étudiants sont en grève
alors pour une jeunesse prioritaire il
faudrait ne pas jouer avec l'aval et la
dévalorisation de certains diplômes
ensuite nous ce que nous demandons est
ce que nous retenons haut niveau de
l'état
nous aimerions qu'ils se réengagent
financièrement au niveau du système
éducatif et plus généralement au niveau
du service public parce que nous en
sommes les principaux usagers et parce
que c'est quelque chose qui paraît
essentielle dans la société actuelle oui
et à ce propos là je voudrais simplement
signaler que nous sommes plus que
solidaires avec les salariés parce que
là sur la question du service public
nous défendons des choses communes et
nous en sommes conscients et que par
ailleurs nous sommes deux futurs
travailleurs de futurs chômeurs de
futurs retraités et je pense qu'on
faudrait pas réduire notre nos
revendications notre raison de lutter et
nous avons des choses à dire je voudrais
qu'on les entende n'est pas uniquement
sous forme de questions n'a beaucoup
plus que ça à dire et on le fera avec
les salariés voilà il y en aurait encore
porter aborder les problèmes alors
l'ingestion de l'université on aurait pu
en parler ils ont été beaucoup plus un
billet intéressant notamment comme
l'exemple du de caoutchouc à clermont
ferrand qui a pas fait suite à lorsque
nous ont faits ont fait appel ce soit
enfin appel dans laurier tous les lycées
à toutes les universités à tous les iut
on attend des lectures à se mettre en
grève illimitée et à nous rejoindre dans
le mouvement puisqu'il réaltor un peu
moins de la moitié donc que tu tout et
je me suis dit j'ai pensé bon orateur de
la tempête aura pas de terminer ça comme
un meeting simplement vous avez vu
attendez je suis obligé de maintenir là
monsieur saint jean vous dire une chose
mais vraiment rapidement parce que où
qu'on s'arrête un moment oui non je sais
bien mais résiste bien et je trouve que
cette émission pourrait être utile et je
souhaite je ne sais pas je sois utile
ce que je voudrais simplement dire c'est
ce qu'on a entendu ce soir
oui de la part de ce qu'ont dit les
grévistes oui des travailleurs/ses de
l'inquiétude profonde et j'ai entendu
monsieur lellouche qui partageaient
leurs angoisses parfait alors si tel est
le cas je crois que vous êtes
suffisamment bien placé pour
demandez à votre gouvernement de
remettre à plat les problèmes les
dossiers de façon à réengager totalement
une négociation
moi je crois que les travailleurs sont
déterminés ils sont aussi responsables
ils défendent leur outil de travail ils
défendent un service public ils
défendent l'intérêt national
ça je crois que c'est tout à fait
exemplaire et il me semble que ce
message vous devriez le marais devant
vraiment rapide pierre lellouche chose
que je veux dire je partage ce qu'a dit
monsieur saint jean une chose que je
veux dire la france aujourd'hui est en
difficulté elle est au milieu d'une
crise sociale grave cette cette crise et
en même temps une chance c'est la
science de débloquer totalement notre
système est de remettre à plat donc de
sauver notre secteur public
nos entreprises publiques notre régime
de protection sociale je souhaite que
cette chanson soit saisie par toulouse
et est vraiment je lance la un appel à
la responsabilité et à l'est la france
est un grand pays qu'est la france est
un grand pays elle peut s'en sortir si
berlin fut la méthode de lâche ça va
bien dans une campagne électorale ça ne
va pas là apparemment ça ne va pas on
est en train de nous dire que ça va
continuer en dehors en train de nous
dire c'est un appel à chaque fois
élargir la grève
alors quand les gens parlent pas notre
langue âge on a l'impression qu'il faut
leur dire par les notes ça ira mieux
mais non il faut continuer d écouter et
prendre d'autres méthodes
et même quand ils ont dit que nous
sommes dans un salon parisien pourtant
on n'y est pas je les comprends très
bien parce qu'ils ont l'impression qu'on
y est et on est tellement loin d'eux une
fac temps en temps quand ça va très mal
on va faire savoir les écouter il s'est
changé cette méthode complètement ça
marche pas la colérique com
- tabarot je crois que les gens
expriment aussi bien les salariés que
les jeunes pas des intérêts
corporatistes ou singuliers ils
expriment un mécontentement général
grave et je crois que maintenant il faut
qu'ils soient écoutés et il faut qu'on
leur réponde les politiques depuis 15
ans ne sont pas bonnes des solutions ne
sont pas bonnes elles s'avèrent dhr
mauvaise
il faut aujourd'hui prendre d'autres
chemins reclus avec monsieur suit aussi
peut-être monsieur soubie et monsieur
fitoussi monsieur ce billet un moment
voyons souvent des issues positives 900
les poisses a fait et je crois pour deux
oui est issue positive faut bien voir
qu'aujourd'hui le kung fu long et que je
crois qu'au fond on vous entend pas
pareil votre vie corps mais c'est celui
de monsieur mythe aussi là où alors on
entend amener un micro à monsieur soli
pardo
vous disiez tous les grands conflits ont
une fin pour gecina rester dans les
industries prochaine et ce qu'il veut de
ce conflit durer des semaines prochaines
et c'est une affaire qui intéresse tout
le monde ici est d'abord le gouvernement
et les dirigeants des entreprises
publiques qui sont les premiers
concernés et donc aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on ne peut rien la semaine prochaine
si on le veut on le peut sûrement
monsieur phyto si vous n'êtes pas besoin
de ce micro vous en avril non non je
voulais dire que si le problème est un
défaut d'avenir il faut produire à
l'avenir je crois que pour produire la
vigne et il faut du dialogue et la grève
est une démonstration de force
elle réussit si elle se transforme en
dialogue si elle est suivie par une
production dernier et j'appelle
production d'avenir et non pas la
généralisation
je voudrais simplement puisqu'il est
venu moment nous quitter pardon je
voulais dire simplement que cette
émission que nous avons voulu ce soir la
rédaction de france 2 c'était notre
mission de service public elle a été
imparfaite elle a été intéressante
je rejoins ce que disait bernard
kouchner les gens ne s'expriment pas
forcément comme nous voudrions qu'ils
s'expriment ils s'expriment comme ils
ont envie de le faire je vous dirai tout
de suite dès ce soir et je le dis à tous
ceux qui ont été nos invités ce soir et
à ceux qui étaient sur les lieux que
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire et si
c'est nécessaire la semaine prochaine
nous referons ce type d'émission
n'hésiteront pas à casser nos programmes
pour cela c'est aussi notre mission de
service public voilà donc ce que nous
voulions faire ce soir j'espère que vous
avez été en partie satisfait en tout cas
tout le monde a pu s'exprimer ce que
j'aurai aussi c'est remercier l'ensemble
de nos personnels techniques qui ont
réalisé l'exploit de organisé cette
émission pour ce soir notre réalisateur
jérôme
rebonds et toute son équipe car croyez
moi cette émission était décidé ce matin
très tôt et nous avons voulu la rendre
effectif ce soir ce que nous sommes
parvenus à faire avec nos moyens et tous
ceux qui ont bien voulu nous aider nos
invités bien entendu voilà je voulais
vous remercier en compagnie de benoît
duquesne nous avons été ravis de vous
présenter cette émission nous vous
souhaitons une excellente fin de soirée
sur notre chaîne bonsoir
[Musique]